COMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER
GOOD AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE THE
COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES. WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND HERE
TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINE. COMPLIANCE
WITH THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS
MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC.
CONTINUES HAVE ACCESS THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEES HERE
TODAY IN THE CAPITAL WAS SOME
MEMBERS ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
REMOTELY. TODAY CENTER PAN AND I
WILL BE HERE AND WE ANSWER
MELENDEZ WILL NOT BE ATTENDING.
THOSE PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONE TO COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY CAUSE TO FEEDBACK IN ACID
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED. THAT YOU USED TO
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURING THE
PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED SPEAK THE POP UP
WINDOW WILL OCCUR OPEN HE ASKED
ON MUTE YOU SAY YES YOU SPEAK
THEN YOU GET BACK NEEDED. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE HEARING ROOM. TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW WE WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH.
TO TELL TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUAL WISHING FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
AND IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO
SIX EIGHT ONE SIX THREE. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN SIX TWO
TWO FOUR SIX TWO. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO MARKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE INDOOR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVE
ON A PUBLIC COMMENTS YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED BY MODERATION DIAL ONE
THEN ZERO PLEASE PRESS THIS ONLY
ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR
AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT.
ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU OR WAIT IN THE QUEUE
FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR
THAT YOUR NUMBER AT THAT TIME
YOU'LL BE UNNEEDED AND YOU ARE
NOW READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY
AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK.
YOU MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO
GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR
FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
MAINTAIN THE DECORUM DURING THE
CUSTOMER THE DURING THE HEARING
AS IS CUSTOMARY. AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO WAS DISRUPTIVE
AND MAY BE REMOVED- AND HAVE
THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED. THIS IS
THE SECOND OF NINE HEARINGS OF
OUR REGULAR SUB COMMITTEE
PROCESS TO HEAR THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSALS AND OTHER
RELATED PROPOSALS WITHIN THE
JURISDICTION OF SUBCOMMITTEE
THREE. THESE HEARINGS ARE
DESIGNED TO ALLOW FOR DISCUSSION
OF ISSUES AND TAKE FEEDBACK TO
INFORM ACTIONS THAT WILL BE
LATER TAKEN. AND LATER BUDGET
PROCESS. IN TODAY'S HEARING WILL
REVIEW THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING. THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF AGING
AND ADULT PROGRAMS IN
COMMUNICATOR LICENSING DIVISIONS
WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES. BEFORE WE
BEGIN I WILL NOTICE THE ABSENCE
OF A QUORUM AND WE WILL CALL THE
ROLL WHEN MEMBERS HAVE ARRIVED
AND SO FOR NOW WILL BEGIN AS A
SUB COMMITTEE. AND AFTER THIS
FIRST PERSON BEGINS WITH LET'S
START WITH- THE PRESENTATION OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON
AGING FROM EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR.
CAROL SWARTS LANDER DIRECTOR
TOWARDS LENDER YOU WITH US. YES
I AM OKAY PLEASE PROCEED THANK
YOU. I'M GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS CAROL SPORTS LANDER I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON AGING
THE COMMISSION WAS ESTABLISHED
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE AS AN
INDEPENDENT STATE BODY TO
SERVICE PRINCIPLE ADVOCATE FOR
OLDER CALIFORNIANS AND ITS
PRIMARY FUNCTIONS ARE TO ADVISED
ADVOCATE AND EDUCATE. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET REQUEST TO
FULL TIME PERMANENT POSITIONS
AND AN INCREASEIN FEDERAL
FUNDED FORTY OF THREE HUNDRED
NINE THOUSAND DISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE. AND TWO
HUNDRED AND NINETY SEVEN
THOUSAND I'M GOING TO PROVIDE
THE COMMISSION WITH RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO MEET STATUTORY
MANDATES AND THE INCREASED
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH MASTER
PLAN IMPLEMENTATION. THIS
REQUEST REPRESENTS THE FIRST
SIGNIFICANT STAFF RESOURCE
AUGMENTATION FOR THE COMMISSION
IN DECADES. THE REQUESTED
DECISIONS WILL ENABLE THE
COMMISSION TO EFFECTIVELY
SUPPORT MASTER PLAN
IMPLEMENTATION CREATE APPROACH A
PROMINENT SOCIAL MEDIA PRESENCE.
AMPLIFI COMMUNICATIONS RELATED
TO THE MASTER PLAN AND PARTNER
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING ON
THE CALIFORNIA FOR ALL AGES
CAMPAIGN TO ADDRESS AGEISM
SUPPORT INCLUSION AND EQUITY FOR
OLDER CALIFORNIANS. AND PROMOTE
A POSITIVE IMAGE OF AGING ACROSS
THE LIFESPAN. OVER THE PAST TWO
PLUS YEARS THE COMMISSION IS
WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTNER WITH AND SUPPORT THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING AND THE
ADMINISTRATION IN THE
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE MASTER PLAN.
COMMISSIONERS PARTICIPATED ON
STAKEHOLDER ADVISORY GROUPS
INFORMING MASTER PLANNED
DEVELOPMENT AND TODAY BOTH
COMMISSIONERS AND STAFF CONTINUE
SERVING ON MULTIPLE ADVISORY
GROUP SUPPORTING MASTER PLAN
IMPLEMENTATION. LAST YEAR THE
COMMISSION COLLABORATED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING TO PLANNING
FUNDING FOR REGIONAL HUBS AND
SPOKES FOR AGING AND DISABILITY
TOWN HALLS FOCUSED ON THE AREA
AGENCIES ON AGING LEADERSHIP
STRUCTURE. THE COMMISSION ALSO
DEVELOPED AND SUBMITTED FORMAL
RECOMMENDATIONS RELATED TO THE
MASTER PLAN IMPLEMENTATION OF
HIS BOOKS INITIATIVE AND THE
HOME AND COMMUNITY BASED
SPENDING PLAN. THE COMMISSION
LOOKS FORWARD TO UTILIZING THESE
NEW STAFF RESOURCES TO CONTINUE
CONTRIBUTING TO THE MASTER PLAN
WORK. AND IMPROVE THE LIVES OF
OLDER CALIFORNIANS INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITIES AND CARE
GIVERS. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT I WILL
TURN IT OVER TO THOMAS CAMERON
TO EXPLAIN THE FUNDING
AUGMENTATION AND AFTERWARDS I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE. THANK YOU. HELLO
THERE HELLO THIS IS THOMAS
CAMERON I AM THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR ADMINISTRATION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
BEIJING- WE SUPPORT TO THE
ECONOMIST ON AGING WITH VARIOUS
DIFFERENT ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCESSES INCLUDING BUDGETS SO I
JUST BRIEFLY WANTED TO GO OVER
HOW THE FUNDING IS STRUCTURED
FOR THEIR PROPOSED- POSITIONS-
WE INITIALLY INTEND TO USE
FEDERAL COVERED RELIEF DOLLARS
TO FIND- THESE POSITIONS
INITIALLY AND THAT WILL THEN
SWITCH OVER TO YOU ARE OLDER
AMERICANS ACT GRANT OR OUR TITLE
THREE GRANT. ONCE WE GET OUR
FINAL NOTICE OF AWARD FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION OUR COMMUNITY
LIVING THE DEPARTMENT DOES
ANTICIPATE AN INCREASE IN-
BASELINE FUNDING FOR OUR TITLE
THREE GRANT AND WE WILL BE
ALLOCATING A PORTION OF THAT TO
THE COMMISSION ON AGING TO
SUPPORT THESE JUNIOR RESOURCES
ARE PLEASE LET ME KNOW IF YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS HAPPY TO
HELP. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
ANYTHING FROM THE L. A. O. ON
THIS. YES THIS IS JACKIE BRAZIL
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
OFFICE I JUST WANTED TO SAY WE
REVIEWED THE BCPS AND HAVE NO
CONCERNS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. S. THANK YOU
CHAIR- THIS IS JOEL BAKER WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND WE
ALSO HAVE NO ISSUES WITH THIS B.
C. B. THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I GUESS JUST BACK TO
THE DIRECTOR- HOW IS THE WORK
PROGRESSING INTO THE OF NEW
INFUSION WE HAVE THE DEPTH THAT
THE- THE- THE MASTER PLAN COMING
TOGETHER. YOU KNOW YOU FEELING
EXCITEMENT THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
ABLE TO REACH A WHOLE LOT MORE
PEOPLE. ABSOLUTELY ABSOLUTELY
YES LOOKING FORWARDTO THE
COMING YEAR. AND SUPPORTING THE
ADMINISTRATION- THE COMMISSION
IS HIGHLY ENGAGED WE HAVE A
GREAT GROUP OF COMMISSIONERS YOU
BRING LOTS OF EXPERTISE TO THE
TABLE. CONFORM THE
IMPLEMENTATION. FANTASTIC OKAY
WE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FOR YOUR
SERVICE- I STILL NOTICE THAT THE
DOCTORS AT PAN AND MS WINDOWS
ARE HERE BUT WE WILL MOVE ON TO
OUR SECOND AGENDA ITEM WHICH IS-
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
AGING. AGAIN FIRST IN OVERVIEW
THE BUDGET FOLLOWED BY AN UPDATE
ON THAT TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
INVESTMENTS. AND JUST TO
CONTINUE TO SAY. LAST YEAR WITH
CODE EVERYTHING WAS SUCH A RUSH
NUMBERS UP. AT CASCADE OF MONEY
COMING A LOT OF NEW PROGRAMS.
AND THIS YEAR WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE TAKE TIME TO DO
OVERSIGHT AND FIND OUT HOW THAT
MONEY IS BEING IMPLEMENTED- IF
IT'S BEING USED MOST EFFECTIVELY
JUST THE PROGRESS OF IT WE KNOW
EVERYTHING IS STILL NEW AND
STILL COMING DOWN- AND THEN.
CONTINUE TO HEAR ABOUT WHAT
WE'RE DOING GOING FORWARD- SO
NOW CAN BEGIN WITH DIRECTOR
SUSAN TOMORROW'S OF THE
DEPARTMENT. OF AGING DIRECTOR
ARE YOU READY TO BEGIN. I AM
READY GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR A
MAN I'M SUSAN THE MORRIS AND I'M
HONORED TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING'S
BUDGET. FOR MY FIRST TIME AS CDA
DIRECTOR. MY PREDECESSOR
CHEMICALLY WADE NOW SERVES AS
THE SENIOR ADVISER TO GOVERNOR
NEWSOM ON AGING DISABILITY AND
ALZHEIMER'S. THE SENIOR ADVISER
ROLE FULFILLS A KEY LEADERSHIP
RECOMMENDATION IN BOTH THE
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING AND THE
GOVERNOR'S ALZHEIMER'S
PREVENTION AND PREPAREDNESS TASK
FORCE REPORT. I WANT TO START BY
EXTENDING MY DEEPAPPRECIATION
TO YOU AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE AND TO YOUR STAFF
FOR YOUR WORK ON CTA'S CURRENT
YEAR BUDGET. AS YOU JUST SAID
THE CASCADING- INVESTMENTS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE BUT THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
MADE- IN THE CURRENT YEAR FOR
OLDER ADULTS PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND FAMILY CARE
GIVERS AND WE'RE VERY EXCITED
TODAY TO SHARE WITH YOU. OUR
DEPARTMENTS PROGRESS TO DATE.
TOGETHER WE'RE BUILDING A MORE
EQUITABLE ST FOR ALL AGES AND
ABILITIES. LAST MONTH WE
CELEBRATED THE ONE YEAR
ANNIVERSARY OF THE LAUNCH OF THE
CALIFORNIA MASTER PLANNED FOR
AGING. THIS TEN YEAR BLUEPRINT
FOR OUR STATE SET FIVE BOLD
GOALS FOR TWENTY THIRTY. THIS IS
THE YEAR WHEN ONE IN EVERY FOR
CALIFORNIANS WILL BE AGE SIXTY
OR OLDER. WITH ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TWO MASTER PLAN
INITIATIVES IN JUST THE FIRST
TWO YEARS ALONE. WERE EAGER TO
REPORT TO YOU ON THE WORK
UNDERWAY AND THE IMPORTANT WORK
STILL TO COME. GOING FORWARD
WERE GUIDED BY SEVERAL ROBUST
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS AND A PUBLIC
FACING DATA DASHBOARD TO ENSURE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
. SINCE THE OUTSET AND STILL TO
THIS DAY THE CUPBOARD PANDEMIC
HAS DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
OLDER ADULTS. ESPECIALLY OLDER
ADULTS OF COLOR AND THOSE LIVING
IN LONG TERM CARE. CDA IS
EXTREMELY PROUD OF OUR ROLE IN
THE STATE'S COLLECTIVE EFFORTS
TO ACHIEVE EQUITY AND INCLUSION
NOT ISOLATION. TO PROMOTE
VACCINATIONS AND BOOSTERS. AND
TO SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS LIVING AT
HOME AS WELL AS THE MOST
VULNERABLE AND NURSING HOMES.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
ENABLES US TO CONTINUE THIS
CRITICAL WORK WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY BUILDING OUT OUR
WORK FORCE. AND NETWORK CAPACITY
TO EXTEND THE REACH OF OUR
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES TO FAR
MORE OLDER ADULTS. PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND FAMILY CARE
GIVERS. WE VERY MUCH LOOK
FORWARD TO PARTNERING WITH YOU
AND THE LEGISLATURE ON ALL OF
THE PROPOSALS AND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. BEING A NEW DIRECTOR I
AM SO GRATEFUL TO OUR INCREDIBLE
CDA STAFF TEAM AND I AM PLEASED
TODAY TO BE JOINED BY OUR DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR ADMINISTRATION
THOMAS CAMERON WHO YOU JUST
HEARD FROM. THE WILL WALK
THROUGH RBC KEYS AND ALSO OUR
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR MARK
BAGLEY WHO WILL RESPOND TO
QUESTIONS ON THE AGENDA. THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY AND I
TURN IT OVER TO THOMAS NOW THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND WELCOME
DIRECTOR. THANK YOU. YOU BACK
WITH US THOMAS. YES MA'AM HELLO
AGAIN CHAIR. THOMAS CAMERON W.
DIRECTOR FOR ADMINISTRATION WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING. ARE
BRIEFLY I'M JUST GOING TO WALK
THROUGH OUR PROPOSED BUDGET FOR
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
AND THEN- RUN THROUGH OUR BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSALS INCLUDED AS
PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET-
ARTICLES FUNDING LEVEL FOR
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE IS TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHT MILLION.
DOLLARS IN THAT HAS BROKEN OUT
BETWEEN GENERAL FUND AT SIXTY
SEVEN POINT NINE MILLION.
FEDERAL FUND. AT A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY ONE POINT ONE MILLION.
SPECIAL FUNDS TOTALING SIX
MILLION DOLLARS ROUGHLY.
REIMBURSEMENTS TOTALING THIRTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS. AND AGAIN THAT
BRINGS US TO A TOTAL OF TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS FOR OVERALL BUDGET. THE
ONENOTE I WILL MAKE AS YOU'LL
SEE IN THE AGENDA THERE IS A
MARKED CHANGE FROM OUR PRIOR
YEAR BUDGET TO OUR CURRENT YEAR
BUDGET I JUST QUICKLY WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT. THAT IS DUE TO THE
HOME AND COMMUNITY BASED
SETTINGS SPENDING PLAN
INVESTMENT TOTALING THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS BEING INCLUDED IN OUR
CURRENT YOUR BUDGET AS WELL AS-
OUR FEDERAL FUND. BUDGET
AUTHORITY BEING INCREASED TO
ACCOUNT FOR THE VARIOUS
DIFFERENT COVERT RELIEF FUNDS
THAT ARE NOTED FURTHER DOWN THE
AGENDA. NOT STAND I KNOW GOING
TO GIVE IT A GO THROUGH OUR
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS. THE
DEPARTMENT AGING HAD THREE
PROPOSALS INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. I'LL START
WITH THE LARGEST ONE WHICH IS
RESOURCES TO CONTINUE THE
IMPLEMENTATION FOR THE MASTER
PLAN FOR EACH. THE PROPOSAL
PROVIDED TWO MILLION DOLLARS
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE. AND TURNING TO ONE
POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT TWELVE NEW
POSITIONS AT CDA- IN THE AREAS
OF DATA AND RESEARCH. EQUITY IN
TRIBAL LEADERSHIP. POLICY
LEADERSHIP PUBLIC EXTERNAL AND
STAKEHOLDER COMMUNICATIONS AS
WELL AS ADDING A NEW FUNCTION
WITH THE DEPARTMENT THE STATE
PUBLIC GUARDIAN LIAISON.
ADDITIONAL IN THE DEPARTMENT WAS
PROVIDED WITH PROPOSED RESOURCES
FOR A INCREASED ADMINISTRATIVE
WORKLOAD DO YOU TO THE GROWTH OF
THE DEPARTMENT AND TO CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT THE MASTER PLAN ON
AGING- AND THAT IS FOR
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS TOTALING
FIVE HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE- AND FIVE
HUNDRED AND TWELVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR AN ON GOING. THOSE
FOR RESOURCES ARE SPLIT BETWEEN
OUR HUMAN RESOURCES AND OUR
BUSINESS SERVICES TOOL.
ADDITIONALLY JUST A NOTE WE DID
HAVE A TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT
BOZELL TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
POSITION OF FORTY TO TRUE UP OUR
BUDGET FOR POSITIONS THAT WE
HAVE BEEN FUNDING WITH EXISTING
RESOURCES AND THAT IS A TOTAL OF
EIGHT- EIGHT POSITION. EIGHT
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS OR POSITION
I FORTY FOUR EIGHT CURRENT
STAFFING. IF YOU HAVEN'T PLEASE
LET ME KNOW. AND NOW HEADING OFF
TO MARK FACT WE ARE CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR. WELCOME CHIEF DEPUTY.
AFTERNOON THAT YOU'RE EGGMAN
IT'S GREAT TO BE HERE TODAY I
WILL- ADDRESS THE QUESTIONS THE
AGENDA. STARTING WITH THE FIRST
QUESTION WHICH HAS TO DO WITH
OUR NEW PROPOSED- PUBLIC
CONSERVE YOUR LIAISON POSITION-
AND THE QUESTION IS HOW WOULD
THE REQUESTED POSITION ENSURE
CONSISTENCY IN EQUITY AMONG ALL
HE G. CA OFFICES STATEWIDE- SO
CDA PROPOSES TO ESTABLISH- A
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE LOCAL
PUBLIC GUARDIAN OFFICES. AS IT
RELATES TO THEIR PROBATE
CONSERVATORSHIP FOR OLDER
ADULTS- WE THINK THIS IS AT A
CRITICAL RELATIONSHIP TO
ESTABLISH AND WAS HIGHLIGHTED AS
ONE OF THE KEY INITIATIVES IN
THE MASTER PLAN FOR AGING- AS
THE PUBLIC GUARDIAN'S PLAY A
CRITICAL ROLE IN ENSURING THE
HEALTH OF MATERIAL LEADS. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO CANNOT CARE FOR
THEMSELVES SUCH AS INDIVIDUALS
WITH. COGNITIVE IMPAIRMENTS AND
MENTAL AND PHYSICAL DISABILITIES
AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ISSUES- WE
SEE THE ROLE OF THE WAYS ON TO
BRING TOGETHER ALL STAKEHOLDERS
THAT- TOUCH PROBATE
CONSERVATORSHIP. SERVICE WOULD
INCLUDE LOCAL PAP'S GPC OFFICES
PTA P. G. HE SI ESTAS SITUATION%
AS WELL AS THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL-
AND YOU KNOW OF COURSE THAT ALSO
INCLUDED IN THOSE CONVERSATIONS
OTHER ADVOCATES AND FAMILY
MEMBERS- AND THE PURPOSE OF THIS
DISCUSSION SHOULD REALLY BE TO
IDENTIFY THE GAPS NEEDS AND
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR PROBATE
CONSERVATORSHIP AND- WHAT THIS
POSITION WOULD DO IS REALLY TO
TAKE A STATE WIDE VIEW OF THE
LOCAL OFFICES- FOUNDATIONAL TO
DOING THIS REVIEW AND ANALYSIS
IS REALLY GOOD DATA. SO IN OUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE PAP'S GPC
ASSOCIATION. WHAT WE'VE-DISCOVERED IS THERE'S A LACK OF-
STATEWIDE RELIABLE DATA AND-
WHEN IT COMES TO THE NUMBER OF
PROBATE CONSERVATORSHIP OF
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE STATEWIDE- AS
WELL AS THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF THE
INDIVIDUALS- AND SURVIVE. AS A
CONSERVATORSHIP. SO WHAT THIS ON
DO IS REALLY- HOW. FACILITATE
THE ACT COLLECTION OF THAT DATA
AND TALK TO STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT
THE TYPE OF DATA THAT NEEDS TO
BE COLLECTED- ONCE WE HAVE THIS
DATA COLLECTED THEN WE THINK
THAT WE CAN HAVE REALLY GET
MEANINGFUL DISCUSSIONS- ABOUT
THE CASTING IT'S AN
OPPORTUNITIES OF THE PROGRAM.
AND REALLY START BUILDING
TOWARDS A MORE CONSISTENT
EQUITABLE- CONSERVATORSHIP
PROGRAMS STATEWIDE- ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS ON THIS ITEM. SO
YOU'RE YOU'RE A- THE ROLE THEN
WILL BE FOR THIS PERSON TO
COORDINATE WITH ALL THE LOCAL
COUNTY PUBLIC GUARDIAN OFFICES
AND SO RIGHT AND THIS LAYS ON
THEN WILL BE. DEVELOPING THE
DELETED DATA COLLECTION TOOL FOR
THE DATA COLLECTION TOOLS
ALREADY IN PLACE DO WE KNOW.
WE'RE NOT AWARE THAT THERE IS I
KNOW THAT- LOCAL PPG PC OFFICERS
ATTEMPT TO COLLECT. DATA ON- THE
CONSERVATORSHIP SOMETHING
ESTABLISHING WHO THEY SERVE- WE
THINK THAT THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
ALSO PLAYS A CRITICAL ROLE AS
THEY KEEP ALL OF THESE CONSERVE
SHIPS ON FILE. SO WE REALLY SEE
IT AS BEING A COLLABORATIVE
PROCESS AND WORKING WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO. DETERMINE THE
DATA THAT NEEDS TO BE COLLECTED
AND THEN DETERMINING WHO'S THE
BEST NGH YOU CENTRALLY COLLECT
THIS DATA WHETHER IT'S CA OR
ANOTHER AND SHE- BUT DEFINITELY
THIS LAYS ON WOULD BRING. ALL
THE DATA TOGETHER AND HOPEFULLY
PRESENT IN THE FORM O
DASHBOARD- THAT WOULD BE EASILY
TO UNDERSTAND AND ACCESSIBLE AND
DO DO WE HAVE ANY IDEA AT THIS
POINT. AND I'VE BEEN TALKING A
LOT WITH THE PUBLIC GUARDIAN'S
FOLKS DO WE HAVE ANY IDEA. AND
THESE BY DEFINITION ARE OLDER
ADULTS WITHOUT A LOT OF. YOUR
SOCIAL SUPPORT AT THREE UNDER A
CONSERVATORSHIP DO WE HAVE ANY
IDEA WHERE THEY'RE WITH WHERE
THEY ARE PHYSICALLY OR THE END.
OF THE INTRACELLULAR LICENSE OR
THE IMPORTANT CARERS ARE THEY
STILL AT HOME WITH SUPPORTS. DO
YOU HAVE ANY DATA ON THAT YET.
HE DOWN AND YOU KNOW MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THERE IN A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT SETTINGS.
BUT THAT'S EXACTLY THE REASON
WHY I WOULD WANT TO ESTABLISH
THIS POSITION IS SO THAT WE CAN-
GO THROUGH THAT PROCESS OF
COLLECTING THAT DATA
UNDERSTANDING WHERE- FOLKS ARE
HOUSED IN PLACE- AS WELL AS
LOOKING AT PLACEMENT ISSUES- YOU
KNOW OBVIOUS. WAY WITH THE
INCREASE IN THE HOMELESS
POPULATION AND OLDER ADULTS-
BECOMING YOU KNOW A YOU KNOW A
MAJOR PART OF THE HOMELESS
POPULATION- I THINK THAT WOULD
BE ANOTHER PART OF THE
CONVERSATION IS. LICENSE I ALSO
WANT TO MENTION I THINK THAT WE-
HAD NEWLY ESTABLISHED WHAT WE
CALL AN ELDER DISABILITY.
JUSTICE COORDINATING COUNCIL I
WITHIN THE ADMINISTRATION. AND
WE THINK THAT THIS WOULD BE A
GOOD PLACE TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AS WE BRING A
VARIETY OF. DIFFERENT
STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER- THAT YOU
KNOW DEAL WITH- ELDER JUSTICE
RIGHTS. AS WELL AS- YOU KNOW WE
COULD ALSO REACH OUT TO HOUSING
STAKEHOLDERS AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS I CAN ALSO. BENEFIT
PEOPLE. WHO ARE IN
CONSERVATORSHIP. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SURE OKAY I WILL MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT QUESTION A GENDER
WHICH IS- PLEASE DESCRIBE THE
GROWTH IN THE MSSP PROGRAM
ANALYSIS GROWTH HAS. AND WILL
IMPACT ISOLATION AND WELL BEING
AMONG SENIORS- SO THE MSSP
PROGRAM IS A PROGRAM THAT WE ARE
VERY- IOTA- YOU KNOW THE KEY
BENEFIT. THE MULTI SERVICES
SENIOR SERVICES PROGRAM IS TO
ENABLE INDIVIDUALS TO STAY IN
THEIR HOMES AND TO HAVE- HEALTH
AND CARE MANAGEMENT- FROM THEIR
HOMES- YOU'RE A TEAM OF NURSES
SOCIAL WORKERS. ORDINATING WITH
HEALTH CARE AND SHE'S. SO IN THE
CURRENT YEAR THE LEGISLATURE DID
APPROVE AN AUGMENTATION TO
ALLOW. THE MSSP PROGRAM TO
RETURN TO THAT TOTAL NUMBER OF
SLOTS IT HAD. PRIOR TO THE-
RECESSION SO BACK TO ITS TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT LEVEL. OF ELEVEN
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED FORTY
SLOTS THAT'S TWO THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN- NEXT NEW
SLOTS STATEWIDE- AND SO THE-
MSSPS SITES ARE IN THE PROCESS
RIGHT NOW OF STAFFING AFTER THE
SLOTS. THE SPONSOR JUST RECENTLY
APPROVED BY CMS AND BECOME
EFFECTIVE JANUARY FIRST SO THEY
HAVE A STACKED STAFFING ACTIVELY
UNDER WAY- WE SEE MULTIPLE
ADVANTAGES- FOR PARTICIPANTS IN
THE MISSISSIPPI PROGRAM. AS I
MENTIONED TO BE- HEALTH
MANAGEMENT. THEY HAVE A NURSE
AND A SOCIAL WORKER ASSIGNED TO
THEM THEY ARE- THEY RECEIVE A
COMPREHENSIVE ASSESSMENT TO
UNDERSTAND ALL THEIR PHYSICAL
HEALTH AND AT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
NEEDS. AND MEDICARE PLAN IS PUT
TOGETHER AND IT'S ACTIVELY
MONITORED MANAGED THROUGH. ON
THE SOCIAL WORKER AND THROUGH-
NURSING STAFF AND AS CONDITIONS
WITH THE PATIENT CHANGE
OBVIOUSLY THEIR CARE PLAN ON
CHANGES- RELATED ISOLATION WE
THINK THAT THE CARE TEAM.
DEFINITELY PROVIDES MUCH NEEDED
SOCIAL CONNECTION- TO THE
INDIVIDUALS SO THEY MEET WITH
THEM- PERIODICALLY- SOMETIMES AS
MUCH S WEEKLY OR MULTIPLE TIMES
A WEEK DEPENDING ON WHAT THEIR
CARE SITUATIONS. SO THEY GET
CONNECTION ARM- AND THEN ON IF
THEY HAVE ANY PAYROLL HEALTH NAY
. OF THOSE AT ALL BE SENT OUT
TO. BY THE CHURCH. I I'D SAY IN
KNOW AGAIN THE KEY IS REALLY A
FOLKS ROOM IN THEIR HOME AND DO
THAT THIS HAS A POSITIVE IMPACT
IN MITIGATING ISOLATION AND
LONELINESS AND THAT IF SOMEBODY
CAN STAY IN THEIR HOMES IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES THEY'RE MORE LIKELY
TO BE CLOSE MORE CLOSELY
CONNECTED TO FAMILY AND FRIENDS
WITHIN THEIR COMMUNITIES SO YEAH
WE DO THINK OVERALL THE AMNESTY
PROGRAM SERVES. A VALUABLE ROLE
AND I'M MEDICAID ASIC MITIGATING
SOCIAL ISOLATION. AND PROVIDING
FOR EFFECTIVE CARE MANAGEMENT-
ANY QUESTIONS ON THIS ITEM HAVE
YOU GO THROUGH ALL OF THE
MINIMAL OKAY. OKAY TEAM. OKAY
WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE- QUESTION
ON THE TRESTLE. THE QUESTION IS
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
ACT- PROVIDED ADDITIONAL FUNDING
TO PROVIDE MORE MEALS AND
SUPPORT INFRASTRUCTURE CAPACITY
FOR THE SENIOR NUTRITION
PROGRAM. HOW HAS THE STATE MAY
PROGRESS IN ADDRESSING HUNGER
AMONG OLDER ADULTS. HOW ARE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND CAPACITY
FUNDS BEING USED AND WHAT
CHALLENGES HAVE THE PROGRAM
SPACE DURING THE PANDEMIC AND
HOUSES STATE OVERCOME THEM. SO
I'LL START OFF AN EXAM OF THE ME
PROGRAM WHICH WAS EXTRAORDINARY
INSIGNIFICANT DURING THE
PANDEMIC. SO THE STATE WAS ABLE
TO INCREASE ITS MALES. BY NINE
POINT FIVE MILLION AND THAT IS
ALL THANKS TO OUR LOCAL AREA
AGENCY ON AGING- PARTNERS AS
WELL AS OUR NUTRITION PROVIDERS.
HI THERE THIS SERVICE
REPRESENTATIVE 52% INCREASE
APPROPRIATE PANDEMIC LEVELS. AND
SO THE TOTAL NUMBER OF MEALS
SERVED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
FISCAL YEAR. WAS TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY
THREE THOUSAND SO. YES AN
EXTRAORDINARY RISE AN INCREASE
IN TOTAL- MEALS SERVED FIRE
PROGRAMS- THERE'S A QUITE ABOUT
. HOW THE MEALS- YOU KNOW HELP
ME VIA EMAIL GAP- THAT CURRENTLY
EXISTS IN CALIFORNIA AND MODEL
POINTS YOU HERE'S CHU STUDIES-
THE FIRST STUDY AS DONE BY A
NONPROFIT CALLED FEEDING AMERICA
AND THEY PUBLISH AN ANNUAL
REPORT ALL THE STATE OF SENIOR
HUNGER IN AMERICA- SO THEY
DIDN'T UPDATE FOR THE TWENTY
NINETEEN CALENDAR YEAR. AND WHAT
THEY ESTIMATE IS UP THIRTY SIX
POINT THREE CALIFORNIANS OLDER
ADULTS IN CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE
SOME LEVEL OF FOOD INSECURITY
AND ONE POINT NINE MILLION OR
ONE POINT 9% EXCUSE ME AN
EXPERIENCE VERY LOW- FOOD
INSECURITY- AND THEN RECENTLY IN
THE FALL A CONSULTANT- DINA
JOHNSTON- DID A STUDY ON BEHALF
OF THE LOCAL AREA AGENCY ON
AGING ASSOCIATION. DID YOU A
MAIL GAP ANALYSIS AS WELL AND
WHAT THEY FOUND IS APPROVED AND
THEN MAKE BASS MADE AT THE TOTAL
MEAL GAP TO BE EIGHT HUNDRED
FORTY TWO MILLION MALES ARE FOR
OLDER ADULTS IN CALIFORNIA. AND
DURING THE PANDEMIC THROUGH ALL
THE NUMEROUS- AUGMENTATIONS THAT
WERE RECEIVED BY CALFRESH THE
FOOD BANKS- OLDER AMERICANS ACT
PROGRAMS AS WELL AS THE OTHER
EMAIL PROGRAMS STATEWIDE THE
FACT GAP IT SHRUNK BY FOUR
HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO MILLION
MEALS TWO TO THREE HUNDRED
SEVENTY MILLION MALES WE'RE
STILL ANALYZING THAT REPORT- AND
MEETING WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO
DISCUSS IT AND- WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO TRACK- REFINERY OR
ESTIMATES. OF THE GAP- IN
CALIFORNIA BUT WE DEFINITELY
THINK THAT THE ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS RECEIVED DURING HAVE
IT MADE A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON-
SENIOR HUNGER AND SENIOR
NUTRITION. DURING THE PANDEMIC.
AND THEN INTO OF- CHALLENGE ARE
FACED BY- OUR PROVIDER DURING
THE CARE IT AND I CAN. I AM THE
OUTSET OF THE PANDEMIC-
DEFINITELY. SENATE JOHN RAMPS UP
- THERE IS A INFLUX OF MONEY
THERE'S A LOT AT ASTON- BUT
BECAUSE NEWS IS FIVE AWAITS OF
TWENTY TWENTY EARLY FALL- WE'VE
SEEN A RAPID AND SIGNIFICANT
GROWTH IN THEIR CAPACITY TO
SERVE- OLDER ADULTS- SO THEY
REALLY IN A STEP FORWARD AND
WERE ABLE TO RAMP UP QUICKLY-
MORE RECENTLY- A CHALLENGE THAT
WE'RE SEEING IS- THE RESUMPTION
AND OF. IN PERSON OR CONGREGATE
MEAL SITES. SO THE STATE HAD PUT
TOGETHER A PROGRAM MEMO LAST
SUMMER. AND IN THE- LOCAL AREA
AGENCY ON AGING ASSOCIATION OR
C. FOR A- AB PUBLISHED A BEST
PRACTICES RESOURCE AND TOOL KIT.
TO A SYSTEM BE- REOPENING SAFE
OPENING OF CONGREGATE SITES-
THAT WAS DELAYED DUE TO THE
ONSET OF DELTA AND THE OMICRON
VIRUS- BUT WE'RE HOPING AS- THE-
VIRUS SUBSIDES AND AS- HAS KIDS
AND YOU KNOW. HE GOT MORE
AVAILABLE AND CONGREGATE SITES
ARE ABLE TO RESTRUCTURE TO
PROVIDE SAFE MAIL DELIVERY. THAT
PROVIDERS WILL BE ABLE TO REVIEW
RESUME CONGREGATE ON SERVICES-
THIS YEAR. IN THEN I WILL ON TO.
AND THE LAST QUESTION WHICH
DEALS WITH OUR EIGHT R. C.
CERVICAL IS A WHAT WOULD TAKE
EXPAND- BAT R. C. SYSTEMS SAY.
AND WE THINK THAT THERE'S
MULTIPLE STEPS INVOLVED IN MASS
FIRST AND FOREMOST IS
ESTABLISHING PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN OUR LOCAL AREA AGENCIES
ON AGING AND- INDEPENDENT LIVING
CENTERS I IN ALL COUNTIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA THERE ARE
EXISTING PARTNERSHIPS AND WERE
VERY PROUD TO REPORT. THAT WE
HAVE- INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
WELL WE ALL CALL DESIGNATED OR
ESTABLISHED PROGRAMS FROM SIX TO
FIFTEEN AND WE HAVE INCREASED
THE NUMBER OF EMERGING PROGRAMS-
IN THE STATE AS WELL SO
CURRENTLY THIRTY COUNTIES HAVE
EITHER AN ESTABLISHED OR
DEVELOPING A OR C. THAT COVERS
51% OF CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION.
SO WE ARE SEEING POSITIVE GROWTH
AND DEVELOPMENT- SO WHAT THE
STATE'S FOCUS SAYS IN
COLLABORATION WITH OUR PARTNERS
AT DEPARTMENT REHABILITATION
THAT OVERSEES THE INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS ESTERLY STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE AND PARTNRSHIPS
BETWEEN- TRIPLE A.'S ANALYSES I
DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE AN ADRC.
AND SO WE'RE- WE'RE WORKING A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT- DIFFERENT
COUNTIES TO HERE I HAD TO EXPAND
THE NUMBER OF. EIGHTY OUR SEASON
WE HAVE. MOREOVER URBAN COUNTIES
DON'T HAVE THEM. IT'S A MIX WHY
MY FRANKLY- I WOULD SAY YOU KNOW
ONE AREA THAT WE'RE YOU KNOW
LOOKING AT IS BAD LOS ANGELES
FOR INSTANCE WHICH CURRENTLY HAS
AN ADRC IN JUST ONE PART OF. THE
CITY AND SO WHAT WE'RE REALLY
LOOKING TO EXPAND THAT YOU KNOW
AFTER ON ALL OF THE LOS ANGELES
REGION- BUT YOU KNOW THE OTHERS
THERE ARE I WOULD SAY IT'S
REALLY PRETTY SPREAD OUT BETWEEN
THE NORTH CENTRAL CALIFORNIA-
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COUNTIES.
THANK. SERVICE ANOTHER EFFORTS
ARE UNDERTAKING TO- REALLY- AND
I GUESS CAREFULLY AND
METHODICALLY EXPAND THE EIGHTY
OUR SEEDS IS BRANDING SO WHEN I
SAY ADRC I DON'T THINK IF I WERE
TO SAY THAT YOU YOU KNOW ONE OF
MY FRIENDS OR SOMEBODY ON THE
STREET THEY WOULD REALLY KNOW
WHAT THAT MEANS SURLY THINKING
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW WHAT HALF OF
OUR INITIALS ARE THAT'S TRUE
THAT'S TRUE. THEY'RE TRYING TO
THINK OF A MORE- MAYBE
DESCRIPTIVE- AT. BETTER
DESCRIPTOR FOR THE PROGRAM
SEARCHES ONE DOOR. BECAUSE
REALLY THE PURPOSE OF THE
UNIVERSITIES IS TO ACT AS
ACTIVEWEAR ENTRYWAY INTO ALL.
COMMITTEE SERVICES AVAILABLE TO
OLDER ADULTS AND INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITIES AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES. SO YEAH I THINK
BRANDING IS GOING TO BE A BIT
VERY BIG PART OF THIS IF WE CAN
BRAND OURSELVES FRANKLY I THINK
THAT MORE PEOPLE WILL BE.
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT WE DO AND
MORE WILLING TO I USE OUR
SERVICES- A SECOND PART OF THAT
IS REALLY ACCESS TO SERVICES. SO
WE'VE BEEN TALKING A LOT ABOUT
BUILDING MAYBE A CUSTOMER PORTAL
WHERE FOLKS CAN. GO ONLINE AND
INTERACT- TO YOU KNOW PUT OUT
REFER REQUESTS FOR SERVICES AND
THEN GET REFERRALS FACT- AS WELL
AS CREATING MORE CONSISTENT.
ASKING WHY TELEPHONE STRUCTURE
OF. FOLKS WHO ARE CONNECTED. TO
BROADBAND OR THE INTERNET CAN
STILL PICK UP ON AND ACCESS
SERVICES THAT WAY SURLY LOOKING
AT MULTIPLE ENTRY POINTS. AND
MULTIPLE WAYS THAT PEOPLE CAN
ACCESS OUR SERVICES. AND THEN
THERE'S ALL THE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT GOES BEHIND- SETTING UP IT
ACTUALLY STATEWIDE SYSTEM. WHICH
IS TRAINING SO ENSURING THAT
WE'VE GOT GOOD PERSON CENTER
TRAINING. TRAINING ON ASSESSMENT
TOOLS- TRAINING ON ACCESSING
SERVICES AND TRANSITION
SERVICES. FOR ALL OF OUR ADRC
PARTNERS USE- AND THEN
ESTABLISHING GOOD GOVERNANCE
PROCESS TO RECEIVE THE PROGRAM
AND MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE.
MAKING CHANGES TO THE PROGRAM
WHEN APPROPRIATE- BUT YEAH SO
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE KEY- HE
ASKED STEPS WE THANK. WELL I
GUESS ALL THIS MENTION ONE OTHER
THING WHICH IS. THE KEY ROLE
THAT HEALTH PARTNERSHIPS PLAY-
IN THE A OR C. SYSTEM. RIGHT NOW
WE YOU KNOW WORK MAINLY WITH-
COMMITTEE BASED ORGANIZATIONS
BUT WE REALLY DO WANT TO
ESTABLISH MORE PARTNERSHIPS WITH
HEALTH CARE ORGANIZATIONS SINCE
WE SHARE THE SAME. IN OUR
INDIVIDUALS AMONG SIR PROGRAM.
AND SO THAT WE CAN REALLY DO.
WHOLE PERSON PERSON CENTRED SIR
. YOUR IDOL MODEL. FOR ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS AND SERVE. OKAY- SO
THAT IS MY PRESENT. IF THERE'S
ANY ON HAPPY TO ANSWER THEM OKAY
THANK YOU CAN WE TO THE A. L.
YES HELLO- IT WITH REGARDS TO
THE SPECIFIC BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSALS WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
OF AGING. I'M WERE STILL
COMPLETING OUR TECHNICAL REVIEW
BUT AS OF NOW NO IMMEDIATE
CONCERNS WILL DEFINITELY FOLLOW
UP ON WHAT THE COMMITTEE IF
ANYTHING COMES UP- IN TERMS OF
THE OVERVIEW OF AUGMENTATIONS.
TO PROGRAMS MADE LAST YEAR-
SIMILAR TO WHAT THE CHAIR
EXPRESSED WE ALSO IN OUR BROADER
OVERVIEW OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET SUGGESTED THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DO THAT- OVERSIGHT-
OF. THE PROPOSALS THAT WERE
INCLUDED IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
GETTING AN UPDATE ON
IMPLEMENTATION ESPECIALLY
GETTING AN UPDATE ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES SO
THAT. THE LEGISLATURE AS A PART
OF THIS BUDGET CYCLE CAN
CONSIDER- IF ANYTHING COULD BE
DONE TO MITIGATE THOSE
IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES BUT
THEN ALSO I'M TO THE EXTENT THAT
WE'RE STARTING TO GET. OUT
PROGRAM OUTCOMES FROM SOME OF
THOSE PRIOR AUGMENTATIONS-
GETTING A REPORT BACK ON THOSE
SO THEN THE LEGISLATURE HAS A
BETTER SENSE OF- WHAT ABOUT THE
SPECIFIC PROGRAM NEEDS TO BE
EXPANDED- BISHOP SHOULD THOSE
ONE TIME INVESTMENT SPEAK CARRY
FORWARD. ON AN ONGOING BASIS- AS
IT RELATES TO BE DEPARTMENT OF
BEIJING SPECIFICALLY I WAS
MENTIONED- THERE WERE A FEW
PROPOSALS THAT ARE A PART OF
THIS BROADER HOME AND COMMUNITY
BASED SERVICES SPENDING PLAN
THAT THE STATE WAS REQUIRED TO
SUBMIT TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. WE RECENTLY RECEIVED
FEDERAL- CONDITIONAL FEDERAL.
IMPLEMENTATION ACTIVITIES FOR
THOSE PROPOSALS. AND SO AS THOSE
IMPLEMENTATION ACTIVITIES ARE
ROLLING OUT AS A PART OF THIS
BUDGET PROCESS THE LEGISLATURE
JUST MAY WANT TO REQUEST FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
DEPARTMENT TO BE KEPT UP TO DATE
ON THOSE IMPLEMENTATION
ACTIVITIES AND CHALLENGES DO
ARISE IN THE NEXT FEW MONTHS. WE
JUST RAISING THOSE FOR OUR
AWARENESS AND ALSO TO THE EXTENT
THAT THEIR SPECIFIC PROPOSAL
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WOULD LIKE
TO TRACK THE PROGRAM OUTCOMES.
THAT WERE NOT ADOPTED IN STATUTE
THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER- WHETHER FOR CERTAIN
PROPOSALS AND- ADAPTING TO A
SPECIFIC PROGRAM REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS- THAT MAKES SENSE
SO THEN WE CAN ENSURE THAT WE'RE
TRACKING- AND THE IMPACTS THAT
THOSE PROGRAMS HAVE. AND THEN
ALSO- IT'LL HELP THE LEGISLATURE
THINK ABOUT THE ONGOING NATURE
OF THOSE PROGRAM ACTIVITIES
MOVING FORWARD. THANK YOU THANK. YOU VERY MUCH THE PARTNER
FINANCE. YOU'RE OKAY. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I'M
WONDERING IF THE IF I DIRECTOR
TOMORROW'S WOULD LIKE TO. LAST
YEAR WE JUST TRY TOREALLY KEEP
GOING BACK AND FOCUSING ON ON
THE FIVE COMPONENTS OF THE
BIGOTED OF CHOICE AND YOU CAN
GET TO TALK ABOUT THAT MUCH I
WONDER IF YOU WANT TO GO OVER
THAT A LITTLE BIT. AND AS YOU GO
OVER THOSE THEN BE ABLE TO WORK
AND TALKING ABOUT SOME OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SOME OF THE
AUGMENTATIONS THAT WE'VE DONE.
AND THAT'S ONE OF THINGS THAT WE
ASKED ABOUT LAST YEAR IF WE
COULD KEEP REFERRING BACK TO
THOSE FIVE THE GOALS AND HOW HOW
THESE- AB. HOW THEY'RE MEETING
THE GOALS WORKING TOWARDS AT
SOME MONEY IF YOU JUST WANT TO
GO OVER THOSE AGAIN JUST TO KIND
OF HIGHLIGHT A BECAUSE I THINK
IT IS BEAUTIFUL AND
TRANSFORMATIVE. AND I AM ONE OF
THOSE PEOPLE WHO TURN SIXTY THIS
YEAR SO I REALLY REALLY REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT HER CARE OF
SENIORS- AND THEN. SPECIFIC
AUGMENTATIONS THAT YOU WANT TO
GIVE AN UPDATE ON. AND OR ANY
IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES THAT
YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE TO
GRAPPLING WITH RIGHT NOW. THANK
YOU SENATOR I'M HAPPY AND I. FOR
THE SECOND TIME I DID NOT GO TO-
INTO DETAIL ON THE FIVE BIG
GOALS OF THE MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING SO JUST TO RECAP FOR YOU
IN THE AUDIENCE- THE FIRST GOAL
IS HOUSING FOR ALL AGES AND
STAGES. SECOND GOAL IS HEALTH
REIMAGINED. OUR THIRD GOAL IS
INCLUSION AND EQUITY NOT
ISOLATION. THE FOURTH GOAL IS
CARE GIVING THAT WORKS AND THAT
GOAL INCLUDES BOTH THE DIRECT
CARE PAID WORK FORCE- THROUGH-
SOCIAL WORKERS NURSES PHYSICIANS
AND FRONTLINE WORKERS INCLUDING
AYE AND JUSTICE. AS WELL AS THE
UNPAID FAMILY CAREGIVERS UNDER
GOALS FOR. AND THEN THE PHYSICAL
IS ACCORDING AGING AND SO THAT'S
REALLY LOOKING AT THE ECONOMIC
IMPACT- ON OLDER ADULTS AND-
MANY OF THE SS I SS P. AND
MEDIKAL- ISSUES. SENIOR PROPERTY
SO WITHIN THOSE FIVE. GOAL AREAS
I WOULD SAY- THERE'S
IMPLEMENTATION- HAPPENING ACROSS
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS- I'M SO
IMPRESSED IN MY SHORT TIME THAT
WERE WORKING. SO COLLABORATIVELY
THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY ALONG WITH HOUSING LABOR.
AND OTHER AGENCIES AS WELL AS
WITH IN THAT CALIFORNIA HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY WERE
WORKING SO CLOSELY WITH OUR
SISTER DEPARTMENTS BECAUSE- THE-
TEN YEAR BLUEPRINT IS SO
COMPREHENSIVE IT INCLUDES. A
VARIETY OF AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS TO ENSURE THAT
HOUSING TRANSPORTATION. HEALTH
SOCIAL SERVICES ARE ALL INCLUDED
AND ADDRESSED SO I'LL LET MY
TEAM TALK ABOUT SPECIFICS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING- WE DON'T.
OWN ALL OF THE INITIATIVES-
THOUGH WE DO TRACK AND MONITOR
AND WE WERE SO PROUD. TO SHARE
THE ONE YEAR PROGRESS REPORT
WITH THE LEGISLATURE JUST A FEW
WEEKS AGO AND WE'LL MAKE SURE
THAT YOU. HAVE A COPY OF THAT
WHERE WE- PROVIDED PROGRESS ON
ALL OF THE INITIATIVES I THINK
WELL OVER. A HUNDRED- HAVE HAD
ACTIVITY- IN THE LAST JUST THE
LAST YEAR ALONE. AND WE REFERRED
TO THE DEPARTMENT OR AGENCY THAT
IS RESPONSIBLE. FOR THE
ACTIVITY. AND FOR AN ENERGY TURN
IT OVER TO YOUR DEBORAH. CAN YOU
ALSO SPEAK A LITTLE TO ALL OF
THAT COORDINATE BECAUSE I DO
THINK IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPRESSIVE
AND ANY TIME YOU DEVELOP A
SYSTEM THAT GOES ACROSS MULTIPLE
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES THERE.
THERE IS A THAT'S EXCITING WHEN
IT WORKS WELL BUT THEN THERE'S
ALSO THE OPPORTUNITY FOR LEFT
HAND RIGHT HAND- AND I KNOW THE
GOAL IS TO DEVELOP A ONE DOOR
APPROACH AND SO PERHAPS YOUR
THEY CAN ALSO SPEAK TO THE- THE
DATA COLLECTION THAT WERE ALL
THAT MAKING SURE THAT THE
COORDINATION IS OCCURRING.
SEAMLESSLY GREAT AND TO YOUR
POINT THE GOAL IS TO MAKE THIS
AS SEAMLESS AND STREAMLINED FOR
THE END USER. THE FOR THE
CONSUMER THE OLDER ADULT THE
MEDICARE BENEFICIARY WHOEVER'S.
ACCESSING THE SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS THAT- IT'S INVISIBLE TO
THEM AND THAT TAKES A LOT OF
WORK BEHIND. BEHIND THE CURTAIN
TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN AND YOU KNOW
OUR SECRETARY SECRETARY- DOCTOR
GALLEON TALKS ABOUT SILO BUSTING
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT ALL OF
US IN THE AGENCY ARE ENCOURAGED.
TO DO IN OUR WORK- TO REALLY
WORK- WITH OUR SISTER
DEPARTMENTS AND THERE'S- A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
COLLABORATION AND PARTNERSHIP
HAPPENING- RIGHT NOW SO I'LL LET
THOMAS AND MARK TALK ABOUT. SOME
OF THE SPECIFICS IN THE MASTER
PLAN THAT ARE ASSIGNED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING AND IM READY
PUTTING UP. ACTION FILM. SILENT
QUESTIONS. YEAH SO- GLAD GLAD DO
THAT- SURE EGGMAN SO- I THINK
WE'LL START OFF BY SAYING YOU
MENTIONED- CHALLENGES AND- YOU
KNOW SORT OF THE STATUS OF WHERE
WE ARE WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF OUR VARIOUS PROJECTS. ALL
HAVE LIKE MAYBE FIVE KEY
INITIATIVES THAT WE HAVE UNDER
WAY IN THE CURRENT YEAR- BUT
WHAT I'LL SAY ABOUT ALL OF THESE
IS. THERE IS A CERTAIN LEVEL OF
INFRASTRUCTURE BUILDING THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE AT THE OUTSET
AND I THINK WHAT I WANT TO SAY
IS. YOU KNOW THANKS SO MUCH
LEGISLATURE FOR UP PROVIDING OR
APPROVING OR SUPPORTING ALL
THESE AUGMENTATIONS AND ALL
THESE NEW INITIATIVES. THAT WE
HAVE THE PRIVILEGE TO REALLY
BUILD AND GROW- IT'S A VERY
EXCITING TIME FR THE DEPARTMENT
OF AGING TO. BE ABLE TO. EXPAND
OUR PROGRAM SERVICES TO SERVE
NEW CLIENTS- IN NEW WAYS. AND SO
YOU KNOW WE'RE JUST EXCITED.
OVERALL JUST TO HAVE THIS
OPPORTUNITY. SO YEAH WHAT ELSE
IS- IN. RECEIVE THESE ARE. THERE
IS A LOT OF INFRASTRUCTURE
BUILDING THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT. AND WHAT
THAT CONSISTS OF COURSE IS
HIRING STAFF. AND I THINK WHAT'S
REALLY CRITICAL THERE IS HIRING
THE RIGHT STAFF SO. WE'VE BEEN
DOING A LOT OVER. THE FIRST SIX
MONTHS. TO GET RECRUITMENTS OUT
TO- GO THROUGH MULTIPLE ROUNDS
OF INTERVIEWS AND RECRUITING
TRULY FINE CAPABLE LEADERS FOR
EACH ONE OF THESE- KEY
INITIATIVES. WE'RE HAPPY TO SAY
ABOUT THE RECRUITING IS GOING UP
VERY WELL- FOR INSTANCE WE HAVE
TWO NEW KIDS ACTED IN CENTRAL
AND- CALIFORNIA PART OF AGING-
WHO'S EVER KNEW- DIVISION OF
AGING POLICY RESEARCH. AND
EQUITY SHALL WE OVERSEEING ONE
OF OUR KEY INITIATIVES WHICH IS.
OUR HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DIRECT
CARE WORKFORCE NINE I HSS FRANCE
SO THERE IS- WE HIRED A
CONSULTANT AND- THERE WERE RIGHT
NOW WORKING WITH THAT CONSULTANT
IN HIRING. A PERMANENT STATE
LEADER OF THAT PROGRAM. SO RIGHT
NOW WE'RE IN THE SCOPING PROCESS
OF THAT PARTICULAR PROGRAM- WE
ALSO HIRED- BONTA KASTRO WHO IS
LEARNING STATE LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN. SO ONE OF THE KEY-
PRIORITIES OF HER AND WITH. THE
ADDITIONAL AUGMENTATION WE
RECEIVED FROM THE LEGISLATURE TO
YEARS AGO IS REALLY EXPAND. THE
VISITS TO NURSING HOMES AND
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE- ELDERLY STATEWIDE. AND WE
HAVE SEEN SOME REALLY GOOD
PROGRESS IN THE INCREASE OF
THOSE VISITS. ANOTHER KEY
EXECUTIVE HIGHER THAT WE NEED TO
GENERATE WAS. LAST SEASON
RODRIGUEZ WHO IS NOW OUR NEW-
OFFICE OF THE STAKE CARE LONG
TERM PATIENT REPRESENTATIVE.
CERVANTES NEW PROGRAM THAT WAS
SET UP. TO PROVIDE
REPRESENTATION FOR. INDIVIDUALS
IN SKILLED NURSING AND
INTERMEDIATE CARE FACILITIES
BRING CAPACITATE IT AND I AM
ABLE TO MAKE THEIR OWN HEALTH.
DECISIONS- THIS PUBLIC PATIENT
REPRESENTATIVES STEPS. INDEX
THREE. AND RIVER OUR WISHES-
WHEN THERE'S NO FOR OR FOR OR
ABLE DO SO- SO THAT PROGRAM WE
AN- HAVING LONG BY. JULY OF THIS
YEAR. AND SERVICE. FROM WORKING
- HER TEAM. TO DEVELOP A PLAN OF
IMPLEMENTATION. AND WE ARE GOING
TO BE MEETING WITH STAKEHOLDERS
WITHIN THE NEXT TWO WEEKS WHICH
INCLUDES CAFFEINE CANNER- AND
OTHER- NURSING HOME ADVOCATES-
TRULY- STAND UP THIS EXCITING
NEW PROGRAM- ANOTHER INITIATIVE
ALL HIGHLIGHT AS ADULT FAMILY
HOMES WHICH IS THE FIRST.
HOUSING PROGRAM THAT- THE
DEPARTMENT OF BEIJING HAS
OPERATED. SO THE ADULT FAMILY
HOMES IS MODELED AFTER DDS IS
SUCCESSFUL FAMILY HOMES AGENCY.
PROGRAM WHICH PLACES INDIVIDUALS
AND IN OUR CASE INDIVIDUALS WITH
COGNITIVE IMPAIRMENTS INTO THE
HOMES OF FAMILIES- SO THAT THEY
CAN FEEL PART OF A FAMILY UNIT
AND RECEIVE THE BENEFITS- OF
BEING PART OF A FAMILY UNIT. SO
WE ARE RIGHT NOW IN THE PROCESS
OF HIRING BELIEVE FOR THAT
PROGRAM. BUT WE HAVE BEEN IN
CONVERSATION WITH GDS THEY'RE
GOING TO REALLY HELP US AS STAND
UP THIS NEW PROGRAM- THE PROGRAM
IS TO- PLACE OBSCENITY. BILLS IN
ONE COUNTY- ITO FAMILY HOMES.
SO- WE SHOULD SOME GOOD PROP ON
THAT THIS TIME- I'D SAY UNDER.
OUR GOAL OF AYE INCLUDE EQUITY
NOT ISOLATION SO DID SERVICES
HAS REALLY BEEN A BIG PARTY FOR
THE DEPARTMENT- WITH THE ONSET
OF THE COVERT PANDEMIC- WE
REALLY SAW THE NEED TO EXPAND.
THE DEPLOYMENT OF TABLETS AND-
SERVICE PLANS AND TRAINING TO
OLDER ADULTS WHO DID NOT
PREVIOUSLY USED SOCIAL SERVICES-
WE KNOW A LOT OF THEM ARE
EXPERIENCING ISOLATION AND
LONELINESS YOU TO STAYING AT
HOME AND BEING RESTRICTED FROM
FAMILIES AND FRIENDS. SO WE-
UNDERTOOK A PROJECT TO DEPLOY
FOUR THOUSAND I'VE HAD
STATEWIDE- I WEIGH ABOUT SEVENTY
EIGHT HUNDRED OF THOSE HAVE BEEN
DEPLOYED SO FAR. AND THEREST
SHOULD BE DEPLOYED WITHIN THE
NEXT COUPLE OF MONTHS- WE ALSO
HAVE TWO OTHER JUDICIAL AND
INCIDENTS. WHICH IS AT A FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS AND- DIGITAL
GRANTS CHIU- COUNTIES. AND SO WE
ARE GOING TO BE MEETING WITH- V.
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION THIS FRIDAY. TO TALK
ABOUT ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY IN
STRUCTURES OF THAT PROGRAM. WITH
THE GOAL. OF GETTING THOSE.
HENCE DONE BY LATE SOME EARLY
FALL. AND THEN ALSO HAVE SOME
MILI AND- FOR THAT WAS. FOR HOME
AND BASED SERVICE FOR. SO RIGHT
NOW OUR TEAM THE SKIP OUT THAT
PROJECT. WHO ARE NATURAL
PARTNERS WOULD BE FOR THAT
PROGRAM AND THEN. ONCE WE DO
THAT WILL EXECUTE CONTRACTS AND
AGAIN THAT PROGRAMS PROBABLY
LOOKING TO BE MAYBE- UP AND
RUNNING BY THE FALL- THOSE YOU
KNOW THOSE ARE ONLY THAT THE BIG
SHE- INITIATIVES THAT WE ARE
CURRENTLY TRACKING- SUSAN OR
THOMAS- LET ME KNOW IF I MISSED
ANYTHING. THIS IS THOMAS CAMERON
AGAIN OUR MARKET YOU COVERED THE
- A LOT OF THE LARGE AN ISSUE
DAVIS- BUT THERE'S A COUPLE THAT
I JUST WANTED TO TOUCH ON AS
WELL IN ADDITION TO WHAT YOU
MENTIONED ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT
ALSO LAST YEAR DID RECEIVE
INCREASED BASELINE FUNDING FOR
OUR SENIOR TRISH WILL PROGRAM TO
INCREASE OUR CAPACITY AROUND
MEALS- AND I BELIEVE THAT IS A-
THIRTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS THIS
YEAR THEY'LL TURN TO THIRTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. ONGOING WE DID
GET THOSE DOLLARS OUT OF THE
BEGINNING OF THE FISCAL YEAR TO
OUR LOCAL AREA AGENCIES ON AGING
AND THEY HAVE STARTED TO EXPAND
THOSE DOLLARS- AND CONTINUE TO
EXPAND THEIR CAPACITY- IN
ADDITION BUSINESS CONFORMANT-
LIKE MEALS ON WHEELS OR VOUCHERS
FOR FOOD. BUT SOUND LIKE HOME
DELIVERED MEALS YOU LIKE MEALS
ON WHEELS KNOCKERS WRITERS. I
THINK. ADDITIONALLY RECEIVED TO
APPROVE FOR YOU OLDER AT ALL
RECOVERY RESILIENCE PACKAGE.
WHICH YOU DO HAVE NOTED IN JEFF
- ON PAGE SEVEN ALL THE VARIOUS
DIFFERENT INITIATIVES SOME OF
THAT MARK SPOKE TO THE ONE THAT
I JUST WANTED TO BRIEFLY TOUCH
ON- OR THE ONE THAT I WANT TO
BRIEFLY TOUCH ON- WAS THE
CONTINUED. SUPPORT FOR. OUR
BEHAVIOR HEALTH FRIENDSHIP LINES
WE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT ABOUT-
AND THOSE DOLLARS NOW WITH THE
CONDITIONAL APPROVAL FROM- CMS.
THE A OF THE H. CBS PLAN OUTSIDE
A NOTE WILL BE ABLE TO AMEND
THAT AGREE AND GET THOSE DOLLARS
I'M CONTRACT CAN TO. THIS OF THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH FRIENDSHIP
LINE- FOR ALL OLDER ADULTS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA ADDITIONALLY
ARE- DEPARTMENTS TEAM HAS MADE A
LOT OF PROGRESS ON THE SENIOR
NUTRITION INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT. IT WAS ALSO
INCLUDED- WE'VE DONE A LOT OF
COLLABORATION WITH OUR TRIPLE A
PARTNERS AND THEY HAVE BEEN
WORKING CLOSELY WITH MEALS ON
WHEELS CALIFORNIA SINCE THAT WAS
THAT THEN BACK- A DOCTOR AS A
LEGISLATIVE INVESTMENT AND AGAIN
THAT IS. FUNDED VIA THE EACH
YEAR SPENDING PLAN SO NOW THAT
WE HAVE GOT CONDITIONAL APPROVAL
WE WILL BE WORKING TO LAUNCH
THAT WITH THE PROPOSED LARGE
STATE. OF JULY TWENTY TWENTY
TWO- ATTY THE OTHER ONE THAT I
WANTED NOTE ON WAS OUR SENIOR
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES- WHICH
IS MODELING AND EXPANDING OUR
TITLE FIVE. PROGRAM WE HAVE DONE
A LOT OF THE BUILDING AND
INITIAL WORK ON THAT EFFORT AND
ALSO PLAN TO BE ABLE TO. EXECUTE
AGREEMENTS AND EXPAND THOSE
SERVICES- THIS SUMMER AS WELL I
THINK WE'RE LOOKING AT- JULY.
THE LAST IN THAT I WANTED TO
NOTE IS DO YOU WANT IT TERMED
YOU PROVIDE. FOR OUR CAP HEALTH
INSURANCE CAL IN AB PROGRAM HELP
WITH MINOR. WE HAVE KICKED OFF
EFFORTS THERE ARE PROGRAMS STAFF
HAS TAKEN THE LEAD AND THAT DONE
THE ENGAGEMENT WITH
STAKEHOLDERS- THEY WORKED WITH A
CONSULTANT TO. DEVELOP A
BLUEPRINT- AND THAT IS WELL
UNDER WAY AND WE ARE WORKING
TOWARDS NOW- TRYING TO IDENTIFY
A PLANS LONG TERM. DEBT RUN THE
GAMUT FOR MODERNIZATION I'M
LOOKING AT THE FUNDING
METHODOLOGY LOOKING ACT- STATUTE
AND ENSURING BOX APPROPRIATE
ALSO LOOKING AT THE WAY THE HIGH
CAPS OPERATE- LIKE MARK TALKED
ABOUT WITH YOUR SEATS ARE
BRANDING. TO ENSURE THAT IT IS
MORE APPROPRIATE AND MORE
INFORMATIVE TO OLDER ADULTS AND
LASTLY ALSO LOOKING TO IMPLEMENT
STANDARDIZED TRAINING AND NEW
TOOLS ACROSS. BOB GRAHAM. AND I
THINK THOSE COVER KIND OF THE
MAJOR ITEMS THAT OUR TEAM. HAS
BEEN WORKING ON THAT- WERE PART
OF THE YEAR'S. THANK YOU. IN
THERE'S ONE FOR THAT I BE REMISS
IF I DIDN'T MENTION BECAUSE
SENATOR CAN WAS SLOW. IN SUPPORT
OF ADVOCATE FOR WHICH IS OUR
FALLS PREVENTION PROGRAM AND SO
IN TWENTY NINETEEN WE RECEIVED A
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR AUGMENTATION
TO- EMPLOYMENT FALLS PREVENTION
PROGRAMS THERE ARE TRIPLE A.'S-
I'M HAPPY TO REPORT THAT IT'S
BEEN. A VERY SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM-
FOR INSTANCE WE CONDUCTED TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED EDUCATIONAL CLASSES
ON FALLS PREVENTION- WE
PURCHASED OVER THIRTY SEVEN
THOUSAND PIECES OF EQUIPMENT. WE
PERFORMED APPROXIMATELY FIFTEEN
HUNDRED HOME ASSESSMENTS AND
MADE ELEVEN HUNDRED HOME
MODIFICATIONS. IN A SURVEY THAT
WE CONDUCTED- APART DISPENSED
MAJORITY PARTICIPANTS ARE VERY
HAPPY WITH THE SERVICES THAT WE
REQUEST THAT THEY RECEIVED- I
WILL NOTE THAT. WE HAVE A
PANDEMIC DEFINITELY SET THIS
PROGRAM BACK- SOME PEOPLE ARE
NOT COUPLE HAVING. ONE OF THEIR
HOUSE- TO HOW MODIFICATIONS- IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE DEFINITELY
SIGN UP TAKEN SERVICES- WE
DIDN'T SPEND THE FULL AMOUNT OF
THE AUGMENTATION. BUT WE DO
BELIEVE THAT WORKING WITH OUR
TRIPLE A.'S AN INCREASE
PROMOTION OF THIS PROGRAM. THAT
YOU KNOW MORE PEOPLE DEFINITELY
. BE INTERESTED IN RECEIVING THE
SERVICES- AND IT DEFINITELY
PROVIDES A VALUABLE SERVICE
FALLS ARE ONE OF THE LEADING
CAUSES OF DEATH AB OLDER ADULTS.
SO THIS IS DEFINITELY CRITICAL
PROGRAM THAT WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO EXPAND AND GROW.
OKAY IT ANY ANY OTHER PROGRAMS
THAT YOU YOU FACE BIG OBSTACLES
OR CHALLENGES AND BEING ABLE TO.
TO MAKE FORWARD PROGRESS ON. NOT
NOW NO I CAN'T SAY THAT WE HAVE
ALL SAY THAT OUR PARTNERS AND
PROVIDERS HAVE JUST BEEN VERY.
SUPPORTIVE AND COLLABORATIVE AND
SUPPORTING OUR INITIATIVES
LAUNCHING NEW PROGRAMS. SO I'M
YOU KNOW I'M NOT. I CAN'T THINK
OF ANY PROGRAMS WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT OBSTACLES OR
CHALLENGES- TODAY. OKAY THANK
YOU AND I WOULD I WOULD JUST ADD
ONE OTHER INITIATIVE THERE SO
MANY AND I APPRECIATE MARC AND
THOMAS- THEIR COMMAND OF ALL THE
INITIATIVES- ALZHEIMER'S DAY
CARE RESOURCE CENTER INITIATIVE
ALSO THAT WE'RE DOING IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ADULT. SERVICES THE SEA BASS
CENTERS AND THEY'VE BEEN
PHENOMENAL PARTNERS IN AND
DEVELOPING THAT MODEL AND
PULLING IN THE EXPERTISE AROUND
THE STATE. FROM ADULT DAY HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS. OKAY THANK YOU.
AND I'M GONNA TURN IT OVER T DR
PAN FOR ANY QUESTIONS RIGHT NOW
BUT FIRST I'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
CALL THE ROLL OVER AN HOUR AND I
THINK WE'RE ALL HERE SO.PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. EGGMAN HERE
MELENDEZ. PAM YEAH. OKAY WE
NOTICE IT I AM DOCTOR PAN ARE
HERE OUR THIRTY PM. THANK YOU
AND REALLY APPRECIATE THE-
PRESENTATION AND- I MEAN THERE'S
A LOT OF GOOD WORK HAPPENING
PART OF AGING I GUESS THAT'S A
STEP BACK A LITTLE BIT AND JUST
. NO SEVERAL YEARS AGO IT ASKED
THE QUESTION ABOUT- YOU KNOW
GIVING THE AGING POPULATION AND
THE DEMOGRAPHIC CHANGES WATER
INVESTMENT NEEDS TO BE AND- ARE-
OUR OUR OF. OUR POPULATION AGING
POPULATION AND I KNOW WE HAD AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ABOUT IT.
SO AN APPRECIATE THESE
INVESTMENTS I GUESS IS. AND I
KNOW WE'RE PUTTING SOME YEAH
MORE FUNDING TO IMPLEMENT THE
MASTER PLAN AND THE DEPARTMENT-
AS ONE QUESTIONS IS THAT- AS WE
GO FORWARD TIME WEDNESDAY YEAH I
THINK SO WE HAVE SEVERAL GOALS
AND WE WANT. ALLOW SENIORS BILL
STAYED HOME MORE LONGER RIGHT
BECAUSE IT'S VERY EXPENSIVE IF
THEY HAVE TO GO INTO
INSTITUTIONS- IT'S A- IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY ALWAYS THE BEST
PLACE. IF WE CAN AVOID TO AND
STILL HAVING AT HOME. ARE WE
DOING ANY SORT OF I GUESS SO.
BUT IT. SOUNDS LIKE WE'RE DOING.
NOW WE NEED TO DO PROGRAM
EVALUATIONS WITH THE VARIOUS
PROGRAM AND S. S. P. AN
OUTSIDER. BUT ARE WE- IS THERE
SOME EFFORTS ARE THOUGHT ABOUT
DOING A SORT OF MORE
EPIDEMIOLOGICAL APPROACH OUR
POPULATION BASED APPROACH AND
SAY OKAY. NOW WE KNOW THE
DEMOGRAPHIC CHANGES ARE
HAPPENING IN OUR POPULATION. BUT
YOU KNOW WHAT PERCENTAGE OF
SENIORS. ARE HAVING TO BE
INSTITUTIONALIZED ABLE STATE
HOME DISPOSAL SO WE GET A SENSE
OF OUR TRAJECTORY RIGHT SELF
KIMA LEE WE YEAH WE HAVE THESE
INDIVIDUAL PROGRAMS AND- I THINK
THERE'S SOME EVIDENCE FOR MANY
OF THEM- EVEN IN FRANCE
ESSENTIAL EVIDENCE THAT THEY-
HELP BUT CUMULATIVELY. WHERE
WHERE ARE WE GOING ARE WE ABLE
TO KEEP MORE SENIORS AT AND MORE
SENIORS ABLE TO STAY AT HOME AS
A PROPORTION OF THE SENIORS IN
THE POPULATION ETCETERA. SO
ASIDE FROM SPECIFIC PROGRAM
EVALUATION THE DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS THAT YOU'RE
IMPLEMENTING- CAN YOU SPEAK TO
WHETHER THERE'S AN AFTERTHOUGHT
TO TRY TO DO SEVERAL POPULATION
BASED APPROACH AS WELL SAYING
CUMULATIVELY ALL THE PROGRAMS
THAT WE'RE DOING IS. MAKING A
CHANGE THAT TRAJECTORY ARE NOT.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR PAN- I'LL
TAKE THE FIRST INTENDED THAT-
WE'RE VERY EXCITED ABOUT CAL AIM
AND THAT'S JUST ONE ON ONE FACET
OF CARE AND SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS FOR OLDER ADULTS THAT-
SOME OF THAT WITH THE CMS WAIVER
APPROVALS FOR CARRYING IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND SOME OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE ON THE
HORIZON WITH THE MEDICARE
POPULATION- USING A POPULATION
HEALTH- LANDS. AS SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE WE'RE DEFINITELY LOOKING
FORWARD TO AND HOW WE CAN. LINK
OUR AREA AGENCIES ON AGING
CLOSELY WITH HEALTH PLANS- TO
THAT END- WE ALSO HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND THERE IS A
PROPOSAL IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AT LEAST- AS FAR AS
ALZHEIMER'S WITH THE HEALTHY
BRAIN INITIATIVE THAT'S LOOKING
AT MORE. ABOUT POPULATION HEALTH
. COACH AND THEN WORK WERE EAGER
SEE THE CENSUS RESULTS IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS THE TWO.
BIG TAKEAWAYS FOR THE NATION
WHERE THAT THE AGING OF THE
POPULATION AND THE
DIVERSIFICATION OF THE
POPULATION. AND THOSE BOTH
INTERSECT WITH. WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING AND WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD TO SEEING FINAL
CENSUS. DATA FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND HOW WE CAN APPLY
THAT PROBABLY WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. ON COMMUNITY
LIVING. AND FUTURE OLDER
AMERICANS ACT FUNDING FORMULAS
AND HOW WE CAN BE SURE THAT
PEOPLE WITH THE GREATEST
ECONOMIC OR SOCIAL NEEDS. ARE
ACCOUNTED FOR AND FEDERAL
FUNDING FORMULAS AND MARK AND
THOMAS IF YOU'D LIKE TO ADD TO
THAT. YEAH I THINK WHAT I AM
WOULD ADD IS WE WILL BE
COLLABORATING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF. HEALTH CARE
SERVICES ON THEIR H. C. B. S.
ROAD MAP- SO. YOU KNOW CAN'T
REALLY SPEAK TO THE SKIP OF THAT
PROJECT BUT I WOULD IMAGINE THAT
THAT PROJECT WOULD INCLUDE AN
ANALYSIS OF DIFFERENT
POPULATIONS WHO MIGHT BE- YOU
KNOW SUITED FOR CERTAIN TYPES OF
WAIVER PROGRAMS WHERE WAIVER
PROGRAMS MAY NEED TO EXPAND-
MAYBE. IN CERTAIN AREAS ARE
OVERSUBSCRIBED BUT I YOU KNOW I
THINK THAT- PROGRAM MIGHT- THAT
PROJECT ALSO MIGHT HELP. TO KIND
OF IDENTIFY WITH THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIANS AGING. YOU KNOW
POPULATION IS AND WHAT PROGRAMS
MIGHT BEST SUIT THEIR NEEDS.
OKAY NOPE IF PRECIADO THAT THAT
SO IT'S I GUESS I GUESS I WOULD
JUST URGE THAT- IN ADDITION TO
SPECIFIC PROGRAM EVALUATIONS AND
WE HAVE A LOT OF DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS HERE. THAT WE ALSO BE
SURE THAT THERE ARE SOME EFFORT
AT. LOOKING AT THE TRAJECTORY OF
THE OVERALL SENIOR POPULATION WE
KNOW IT'S GROWING- AND- YOU KNOW
MAYBE CAN PULL FROM CENSUS DATA
A COUPLE FROM OTHER SOURCES AND
PERHAPS DTS AT CETERA. BUT-
IT'S- YEAH I WOULD JUST SAY IS
THAT- YOU KNOW CERTAINLY DESERVE
A POPULATION THAT HAS- MANY
NEEDS- THAT- AND THAT- OU KNOW
WE WILL BE SURE THAT- WE- WERE
HERE IN THE BUDGET COMMITTEE WE
HAVE THANK YOU KNOW THE PROJECT
OUT TO THE FUTURE THAT WERE ABLE
TO. TO MEET THOSE NEEDS AND I
JUST WANT. OF ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT CAME OUT THE INFORMATIONAL
HEARING WAS IS THAT- IF WE WERE
JUST GOING TO KEEP THE SAME
LEVEL SERVICE. EIGHT AS WE'RE
DOING NOW AND- HOPEFULLY WE'RE
LOOKING AT DOING BETTER AND
OTHER THINGS. THAT WE WOULD HAVE
TO. JUST ON DEMOGRAPHIC CHANGE
ALONE. WE WOULD NEED TO INCREASE
OUR INVESTMENT IN SERVICES FOR
SENIORS BY ABOUT 5% PER YEAR
WHICH IS ACTUALLY LARGER FASTER
THAN OUR- OVERALL GDP GROWTH
AND- OTHER TYPE THING SO-
PRESIDENTIAL EVEN OUR TAX BASE
SO. IT'S SO. BE AWARE LESSONS IS
THERE IS THAT OKAY WELL I DO WAY
SO WE CAN DO THINGS BETTER AND
SMARTER AS WELL WELL NOT OF
COURSE REDUCING THE LEVEL
SERVICE PROVIDING AND SO. JUST
KNOWING WHERE WE ARE AND THAT'S
YOUR DIRECTORY. IT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S GONNA BE IMPORTANT- IN
ADDITION TO OF COURSE KNOWING
HOW OUR VARIOUS PROGRAMS ARE
WORKING AS WELL SO I'M JUST
HOPING THAT- WE'RE ABLE TO TAKE
THOSE. GET SOME SNAPSHOTS OF HOW
WE'RE DING ON AN ONGOING BASIS
SO WE CAN TRACK OUR TRAJECTORY.
AND AND BE SURE THAT WE'RE
MAKING YARD AND INVEST YOU KNOW
TARGET INVESTMENTS. IN THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY POSSIBLE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
DEPEND. ON- WE CAN ALL BE. THAT
ARE ARE. HERE'S BUSY TAKING
NOTES AND- WILL BE SURE TO
FOLLOW UP ON ALL THE ITEMS.
MENTIONED SO AGAIN WELCOME. THAT
THE DIRECTORS AND MARIO SEN AND-
AND YOUR STAFF GREAT JOB VERY
VERY NICE PRESENTATION- WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES AND THEIR ADULT
PROGRAMS. ALL ADULT ALL DAY BUT
JUST DIFFERENT KIND OF PROGRAMS
DELIVERING THE SERVICES. AND I
BELIEVE- DIRECTOR KIM JOHNSON IS
GOING TO START US OFF. TALKING
ABOUT I H. S. S. DIRECTOR
JOHNSON GOOD AFTERNOON HOW ARE
YOU. AFTERNOON I'M WELL THANK
YOU CHAIR AT AND DOCTOR PAN GLAD
TO BE WITH YOU THIS AFTERNOON
AND- PLEASE DO SIGNED US UP FOR
THE SILO BUSTER ACTION COMMITTEE
AND WE HAVE A- COMMITMENT IN
THAT SPACE- AND ACTUALLY I ALSO
JUST WANTED TO YOU'LL YOU'LL
MEET. FOR THE FIRST TIME OUR NEW
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR JUST A
MOMENT OF DISABILITY ADULTS IN
HOUSING INTEGRATION KIND OF ON
THAT THING THAT'S CLEAR RAMSEY.
SO I ARE MAKING SOME STEPS
INTERNALLY TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
MAKING THOSE CONNECTIONS AND
INTERSECTIONS. SO I ALSO JUST
WANTED TO LIFT UP APPRECIATION
FOR THE PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND LEGISLATURE
FOR THE SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS
TO ACCEPT EXPERIMENT. SUPPORTS
ACROSS PROGRAMS YOU'RE NEXT. A
FEW AGENDA ITEMS HERE- ARE
REALLY FOCUSED ON SUPPORT TO LOW
INCOME INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE BLIND
TO ARE OVER SIXTY FIVE OR WHO
ARE DISABLED. BUT THE PERSONAL
CARE SERVICES TO I JUST TESTED
MORE. OBVIOUSLY HAVE BEEN NUMBER
AND THAT'S EFFORTS AND AT AND
ADDITIONAL RELIEF THAT WE
PROVIDED IN TERMS OF CULTIVATED.
AT BUT ALSO NOT ONLY TAKING THAT
OPPORTUNITY- TO DO THOSE AT ONE
TIME BUT ALSO THINGS LIKE THE
FACT THAT PROVIDER PAYMENT
SYSTEM. CAN I JUST ASK THAT
WE'RE LOOKING TO. CREATE
PERMANENTLY ALSO JUST ONE THAT
REALLY RECOGNIZE THE WORK. THAT
WE'VE DONE TOGETHER ALSO
INSURING THAT THAT WORK FORCE
THOSE WHO ARE. SUPPORTING. AT
THOSE POPULATIONS ARE ALSO
SUPPORTED IN WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE JESS. COME AT THE RELEASED
OF THE CARICOM PAPER I ASK. HIRE
WORKERS AND- OF THEIR EFFORTS.
OVER THE COURSE OF LAST YEAR IN
SUPPORTING AT PROVIDERS AND
GETTING ALL THAT GREAT. AB PP
AND MAKING SURE THAT THEY ARE
SAFE AND THOSE THAT THEY'RE
SUPPORTING AND CARING FOR SAFE.
WE ARE ALSO THRILLED AND YOU'LL
HEAR JUST A MOMENT A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT THE LAUNCH. OF OUR
STAKEHOLDER SESSIONS TO DEVELOP
THE CAREER PATHWAYS. WITH A
FOCUS ON RECRUITING AND
RETAINING I JUST US WORKERS BUT
ALSO PROVIDING BACK UPWARD.
MOBILITY CAREER PATHWAY TO THOSE
IN THE WORK FORCE WHO ARE
INTERESTED IN ADVANCING IN THE
HEALTHCARE FIELD. ARE YOU ALSO
HEAR A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE SSI
AND S. S. P. INCREASED PAYMENTS
FURTHERING ECONOMIC SECURITY AT
THE THOSE POPULATIONS. AND
FINALLY YOU'LL HEAR- RELATED TO
OUR WORK OF SUPPORTING THOSE WHO
ARE VICTIMS OF ABUSE NEGLECT OR
EXPLOITATION. ARE THOSE WHO ARE
FUNCTIONALLY IMPAIRED THEIR
OLDER OUR- OUR ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES. PROGRAM AND JUST SO
GLAD AND GRATEFUL FOR THE
ABILITY TO EXPAND THAT PROGRAM
WITH ADDITIONAL CASE MANAGEMENT
AT CONNECTIONS AND APPLICATIONS
FOR HOUSING. AT TRAINING AND
MORE SO I'M GLAD TO BE WITH YOU
THIS AFTERNOON START WITH THOSE
AT PROGRAMS AND I'LL TURN IT
OVER. ACTUAR ACTING DEPUTY
DIRECTOR LEORA PHYLLIS YOU KNOW
TO SPEAK TO YOUR QUESTIONS
RELATED TO I JUST LAST ON. THE
AGENDA THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MISTER WILSON. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MY NAME IS LI OR
CLOSE ENOUGH I AM THE ACTING
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE ADULT
PROGRAMS DIVISION AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. I'M SORRY JUST AS
PROGRAM IS OF REALLY THERE IS A
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE SERVICES
PERSONAL CARE SERVICES AND
DOMESTIC SERVICES TO NEARLY SIX
HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND LOW
INCOME AGE BLIND AND DISABLED
INDIVIDUALS. THE GOAL OF THE
PROGRAM IS TO KEEP HEM SAFELY
IN THEIR OWN HOME AND AVOID
INSTITUTIONALIZATION THEY ARE
SERVED BY APPROXIMATELY FIVE
HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND I JUST AS
PROVIDERS OF WHICH 55% OF THEM
LIVE WITH EVERY STEP YET AND
APPROXIMATELY 74% OF THEM ARE
FAMILY. MEMBERS AND RELATED TO
THAT PERSON. THEY WORK FOR I'M
HAPPY PROVIDE OVERVIEW OF THE- I
. I'M BUDGET. THE TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE I JUST AS BUDGET
INCLUDES POINT NINE BILLION.
DOLLARS OF WHICH FOUR POINT NINE
BILLION OR GENERAL FUND SH IN
TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY TWO AND
EIGHTEEN POINT FIVE BILLION OF
WHICH SIX POINT FIVE BILLION.
IT'S GENERAL FUND IN THE MID
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE YEAR.
TWENTY THERE IS A DECREASE IN
THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET
OF THREE HUNDRED EIGHT POINT
FOUR MILLION AND A DECREASE OF
SIX HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE POINT
FOUR MILLIONGENERAL FUND DUE TO
LOWER CASELOAD- WHICH IS
SLIGHTLY OFFSET BY AN INCREASE
IN THE COST PER HOUR AND HOURS
PER CASE IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT THE GENERAL FUND HAS
DECREASED SIGNIFICANTLY- DUE TO
THE EXTENSION OF THE KOBE AND-
TEMPORARY SIX POINT 2% NOW
INCREASE. ADDITIONALLY THERE'S
INCREASE IN THE TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE BUDGET OF ONE POINT THREE
BILLION. OF THAT NINE HUNDRED
AND FORTY SEVEN POINT SEVEN
MILLION AS GENERAL FUND. DUE TO
CONTINUED CASELOAD GROWTH COSTS
FOR HOURS AND HOURS PER CASE.
FOR ITS IMPORTANCE NOTE THAT
FOR- THE TWENTY ONE ONE TWENTY
TWO YEAR- I AM JUST AS COSTS
INCLUDE HALF OF THE YEAR IN THE
HOUSE YOUR IMPACT OF THE
INCREASE OF MINIMUM WAGE TO
FIFTEEN DOLLARS PER HOUR. WELL
THE TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE BUT-
BUDGET. INCLUDES THE ENTIRE
YEAR- OF THAT THE FULL YEAR OF
THAT FIFTEEN DOLLAR MINIMUM WAGE
. THERE ARE A FEW HIGHLIGHTS IN
THE BUDGET BUT IT'S IMPORTANT
RIGHT NOW ONE OF WHICH IS THE
PERMANENT BACK UP- PROVIDER
SYSTEM THIS INVESTMENT. OF
TWENTY FOUR POINTEIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS IS- MEANT TO SET UP A
BACKUP PROVIDER SYSTEM ACROSS
THE STATE- A PER MONTH MAKE IT
PERMANENT ACTUALLY THIS SYSTEM
CREATES A PERMANENT SOLUTION
THAT ALLOWS- COUNTIES TO- HELP.
I JUST AS RECIPIENTS FROM THE
BACK OF PROVIDERS- ADDITIONALLY
IT- WE HAVE ALSO INCLUDED
THERE'S ALSO AN INCLUSION OF
NINE AND NINETEEN POINT ONE
MILLION. DOLLAR INVESTMENT FOR
THE CONTINUOUS COVERAGE
REQUIREMENT. I'M WHICH COST
MEDIC HOW- TERMINATIONS ARE RE
DETERMINATIONS IN RESPONSE TO
THE PUBLIC NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND
PREVENTS CASES FROM SHIFTING
FROM- FROM UP. SORRY FROM
SHIFTING FROM THE NON FEDERAL
INTO A NON FEDERALLY FUNDED
PROGRAM WHICH IS THE CENTRAL.
ADDITIONALLY THE BUDGET
INCLUDES- A PENALTY REDUCTION
FOR THE LET RECIPROCATION
IMPLEMENTATION- IT COVERS THE
FIRST SIX MONTHS OF PENALTIES
AND- TWICE IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. AND- CHAU AND THEN
LOOKING AT THE AGENDA IT LOOKS
LIKE YOU THEY DID A WONDERFUL
JOB OF OUTLINING ALL OF THE
INVESTMENTS WERE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS WITH REGARDS TO THIS.
WELL WE'RE GONNA TURN IT OVER TO
THE L. A. O. IN A MINUTE BUT I
GUESS ONE OF THE ONE OF THE
THINGS IF YOU COULD JUST SPEAK A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT. IS TO
WHAT YOU CONTRIBUTE THE- THE
DECLINE IN IN CASES. SURE SO
THAT WAS- THE SECOND QUESTION I
BELIEVE THAT THERE WAS- ISSUE
RAISED WITH REGARD OR CONCERN
WITH REGARDS TO THERE'S A SLOWER
SLOWER GROWTH IN THE PEACHTREE'S
. WE BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A
TRIBUTE- AS IT WAS KIND OF
ALLUDED TO BUYER- OUR COLLEAGUES
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING THAT
THEY'RE DUE TO THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC THERE WERE
LOTS OF- INDIVIDUAL RECIPIENTS
WHO DIDNOT WANT TO HAVE
STRANGERS IN THEIR HOMES SO- WE
THINK. BASED ON. ANECDOTAL DATA
THINGS THAT WE'VE HEARD AND
STATE MEETINGS WE BELIEVE THIS
AND- ONE OF THE MANY REASONS WHY
- THERE WAS GROWTH THE PAGE. AND
PAID CASE. BUT WE DO TO LOOK AT
THE PRO DATA TO A- TRÊN- AT TO
SEE IF CAN FIGURE OUT IF THERE'S
ANY OTHER- THINGS HAPPEN OUT
THERE THAT. THAT- IMPACTS THE
NUMBER OF CASES HAVE THE AMOUNT
OF FAMILY CAREGIVERS GONE UP.
AND WHEN WE SAY PETER TALKING
OUTSIDE. PEOPLE WHO WOULD COME
FROM- AN AGENCY. SO ALL OF OUR
PROVIDERS ARE FOR THE MOST PART
THE MAJORITY OF THEM ARE ARE-
INDIVIDUAL PROVIDERS STERN WE
HAVE A VERY SMALL NUMBER OF
CASES ACTUALLY HAVE. AN AGENCY-
EMPLOYEE COME TO THEIR HOME LESS
THAN A HUNDRED CASES SO MOST OF
OUR PROVIDERS ARE- ARE JUST
PEOPLE OUT THERE IN THE
COMMUNITY. 74% AND THAT SEEMS TO
BE STAYING PRETTY RELATIVELY
FLAT THAT NUMBER 74% OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE A PROVIDER WHO-
WHO IS RELATED TO THEM NOT- SO
THE- AND IN SOME CASES. THERE
COULD BE MULTIPLE PROVIDERS ON
THE CASE SO SHORT SO. AND WE
HAVE SEEN OVER THAT- OVER THE
YEARS THAT WE DO SEE AN INCREASE
WITH OF PROVIDERS WHO ARE
RELATIVE PROVIDERS BUT IT'S NOT
AS- IT'S NOT AS PREVALENT. AS AS
ACROSS THE POPULATION. THAT
MAKES SENSE BUT WE'VE HAD THAT
SAID WHAT I'M READING AS WE HAVE
HAD THE SAME AMOUNT OF REFERRALS
AND DECLINES BUT BUT THE NUMBERS
GOING DOWN ABOUT HOW MANY PEOPLE
WERE BRINGING INTO THE PROGRAM.
I'VE BEEN ANY ANYTHING THAT'S
JUST THE PEOPLE DON'T WANT
SOMEBODY ELSE IN THEIR HOME BUT
AT THIS POINT THAT'S JUST
ANECDOTAL IS THAT CORRECT.
THAT'S CORRECT SO WHAT WE ARE
SEEING IS THAT THAT YOU'RE RIGHT
THE NUMBER OF CASES COMING AND
HAS HAS CONTINUED TO INCREASE.
BUT THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE OF
CASES WHO ARE PAID MEANING THAT
A PROVIDER HAS HOME IS CONNECTED
TO THAT RECIPIENT IN TIME SHEET
ACTIVITY- AND THERE'S TRANSIT
ACTIVITY WE'RE SEEING THAT. THAT
NUMBER. OF CASES HAS ACTUALLY
INCREASED OVER THAT PANDEMIC SO
IT'S NOT THE OVERALL SHE SLOWED
IS THE FOLKS THAT. HAVE A
PROVIDER- WHEN WE LOOK AT THAT
AT THE DATA IT SEEMS AS THOUGH.
JUST THIS IS A- DURING CULTURE
NINETEENTH SO PRIOR TO COPE IT
NEEDED WE DID NOT SEE THAT. AS A
WERE TRADING THAT. TO TWO
RECIPIENTSREALLY BE CARE IN CAR
ABOUT THEY HAVE. AND NOT
BRINGING NEW PEOPLE IT SO YOU
HAVE A FLAT RATE. OF YOU HAVE A
NUMBER OF GROUP OF RECIPIENTS
WHO WHO DO HAVE A RELATIVE
PROVIDER BUT YOU DO HAVE A
ANOTHER SUBSET OF RECIPIENTS WHO
DO NOT HAVE A ROLE TO PROVIDER.
AND SOME OF THOSE PEOPLE AS THEY
COME INTO THE PROGRAM MAY NOT
HAVE. A FAMILY MEMBER OR
SOMEBODY WHO LIVES WITH THEM
THAT CAN PROVIDE THEIR CARE AND
THOSE INDIVIDUALS MAY DURING
THIS TIME NOT WANT TO HAVE A
STRANGER COME INTO THEIR HOME
AND PROVIDE THAT'S- BUT- THE
CURRENTLY THEN WE DON'T WE DON'T
KNOW THE STATUS OF THOSE PEOPLE.
IF THEY'RE JUST OUT THERE THE
MORNING CARE WITHOUT BEING ABLE
TO HAVE ANY IN. WE JUST KNOW
THEY WERE PICKED UP ON AND OUR
CASELOADS. SO WE KNOW THAT
THEY'RE NOT PAID BUT WE DO HAVE
MECHANISMS THAT- THAT. COUNTIES
CAN USE TO IDENTIFY WE HAVE
REPORTING BACK TO COUNTIES USED
TO IDENTIFY PEOPLE WHO DO NOT
HAVE A PAYROLL ACTIVELY FOR
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF TIME. AND
THAT'S NOT JUST FOR NEW BUT
THAT'S FOR EXISTING PEOPLE SO
THE COUNTIES DO OUTREACH TO
THOSE INDIVIDUALS TO SEE IF THEY
CAN HELP THEM. WITH A SIGNING UP
PROVIDER OR IF YOU NEED SOME
TYPE OF THIS STEP SO WEAK THERE
ARE MECHANISMS WITHIN THE
PROGRAM. FOR COUNTIES TO DO THAT
OUTREACH. OKAY THANK YOU.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. YEAH I
KNOW I'M CONFIRMING OF FINANCE
NOTHING FURTHER TO ADEQUATELY
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LMAO. IT'S JACQUI YOU
KNOW AND WE RECENTLY OUR INITIAL
ANALYSIS OF THE HSS PROJECT
INCLUDED IN THAT ANALYSIS- WAS
KEY OBSERVATIONS AROUND CASELOAD
AND AS WAS NOTED IN THE AGENDA-
WE DIDN'T WE ARE SEEING THAT- AS
AUTHORIZED CASES AND PAID CASES
ARE INCREASING. THERE IS STILL.
A GREATER DIFFERENCE BETEEN
THOSE TWO NUMBERS OPERATES CASES
AND THEN AMONG THE- PAID CASES
SO PAID CASES HAVE JUST BEEN
INCREASING AT A SLOWER RATE
RELATIVE TO PRE COMBAT NINETEEN
LEVELS- WE'RE WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT TO GET ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION TO SEE- TRY TO
ISOLATE LIKE WHERE IS IT
HAPPENING- BECAUSE AS- THE CHAIR
MENTIONED. WE'RE STILL SEEING
THE SAME NUMBER RECIPIENTS
COMING IN EVERY MONTH THE NEWLY
AUTHORIZED CASES COMING IN EVERY
MONTH THE RECEIPTS SEEING THE
SAME NUMBER OF DENIALS EVERY
MONTH- RELATIVE TO PRE COALPIT
NINETEEN LEVELS AMID AND IN
ADDITION WE'RE HOPEFULLY WITH
THE DATA AND WE CAN GET A BETTER
SENSE OF IF THERE ARE CERTAIN
RECIPIENT TYPES ARE CASE TYPES.
WHERE THIS PARTICULAR TEN JUST
CONCENTRATED SUCH AS LIBYAN
VERSUS NON LIVE IN PROVIDERS I
MEAN MAYBE THAT WILL GIVE US A
BETTER SENSE STEP TO WHAT EXTENT
IS THIS SAD TREND DUE TO
PERSONAL CHOICE- VERSES. UNMET
NEED INDIVIDUALS PERHAPS I'M
HAVING A HARDER TIME TO FIND A
PROVIDER AT THIS TIME. ANOTHER
KEY OBSERVATION- THAT WE MADE IN
OUR ANALYSIS THAT WAS ALSO
REFERENCED IN THE- IT AND THE
AGENDA- WAS THE THAT CONTINUED
COVERAGE AS A RESULT OF THE
TEMPORARY POSITS MEDIC HOW UPSET
REASSESSMENTS WE JUST NOTE THAT-
THAT TEMPORARY PAUSE- UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS ASSUMED TO
GO AWAY. AT THE END OF JUNE OF
THIS YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TWO- SO
ONCE THAT GOES AWAY MEDICAL
REASSESSMENTS WILL CONTINUE
AGAIN- AND AS WE KNOW- PRIOR. TO
THE TEMPORARY PAUSE THERE IS A
DIFFERENT TO TERMS THAT RISK.
THAT WERE NOT I JUST THAT WERE
NOT COULD ABOUT TERM. SOME OF
THEM TERM FROM THE I JUST
PROGRAM WELL- VERSUS SOME OF
THEM BEING. TERMINATED FROM THE
JUST AS PROGRAM I'M SO THE
LEGISLATURE COULD ALSO CONSIDER-
AS A PART OF THIS BUDGET PROCESS
IF IT WOULD LIKE TO TRY TO
ADDRESS- THE POSSIBLE. THE
POSSIBILITY OF DIFFERENT
TREATMENTS. LASTLY AND OUR
ANALYSIS WE MENTIONED- WE
PROVIDED A STATUS UPDATE ON THE
VARIOUS COLBY NINETEEN BUCKS
ABILITIES ADOPTED IN THE I JUST
AS PROGRAM. ONE OF THEM BEING
THERE I MERGING SEA BACKUP
WRITER SYSTEM THAT EXPIRED
DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
INITIALLY AS A PART OF LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET THE INTENT WISE-
ONES THAT EMERGENCY TEMPORARY
BACKUP WRITER SYSTEM EXPIRED IT
WOULD GET PICKED UP AGAIN
THROUGH THE PERMANENT PROVIDER
SYSTEM. BUT DUE TO A DELAY IN
ADOPTING THE PROGRAM MODEL- FOR
THE PERMANENT BACKUP WRITER
SYSTEM IN THE IN STATUTE- D. AS-
IN THE IMPLEMENTATION DATE FOR
THE PERMANENT SYSTEM HAS BEEN
DELAYED UNTIL JULY. SO THERE IS
CURRENTLY A GAP IN BACKUP WRITER
SYSTEMS IN OUR AND OUR ANALYSIS
WE JUST PROVIDED- JUST. POSSIBLE
CONSIDERATIONS THE LEGISLATURE
COULD TAKE IF IT WANTED TO
ADDRESS THAT. SHORT TERM GAP-
WHILE WE WAIT TEST SET UP THAT A
PROGRAM MODEL IN STATUTE- AND
THAT COULD INCLUDE. YEAH I'M
LOOKING AT WHETHER PRIOR FUNDS
FOR THE EMERGENCY BACKUP
PROVIDER IF THERE ANY UNSPENT
FUNDS THAT COULD POSSIBLY BE
EXTENT- THEIR EXPENDITURE THIRTY
COULD POSSIBLY BE EXTENDED UNTIL
JULY. I'M SO WE JUST HAVE THAT
TEMPORARY STOPGAP- AND THAT'S
THE END OF MY COMMENTS HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. DURATION YOU WANT TO
SPEAK TO THAT ONE POINT ANY AND
IT IS OUR FUNDING CAN. WELL
DETAILS BEING WORKED OUT WITH
THE OTHER. YES ACTUALLY WE HAVE
BEEN EXPLORING THAT STAND AND
BELIEVE THAT WE ARE LIKELY TO
HAVE A RESOLUTION TO THE SAME
LEAD COMPLETELY RECOGNIZED THAT
A GAP CREATES MANY CHALLENGES WE
ABSOLUTELY ARE COMMITTED TO
WORKING ON A- PERMANENT SYSTEM.
THAT CAN- ABBY IMPLEMENTED AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE WITH ALL THE
GREAT ENGAGEMENT OF THOSE TO
DEVELOP THE RIGHT SYSTEM. SO AB
WE ARE HOPING TO VERY SHORTLY
ANNOUNCE ADD THAT WE ARE. ABLE
TO BRIDGE THIS GAP IN AND MOVE
FORWARD SO AT. WITHIN MOMENTS
SHOULD BE ABLE TO ASK FOR MATT
APERTURE THAT OUT BUT IT'S
LOOKING VERY VERY PROMISING
MOMENT YOU'RE BUILDING UP TO
PRESSURE HER ANTICIPATED. DR
GRANT. A TRANSIT OKAY OKAY-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THEN
WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT H. AS
CAREER LADDER I THINK THIS
DIRECTOR JOHNSON AGAIN AND IN
ADDITION TO THE SILO BUSTERS I
ALSO WANT LIKE THAT NON STICK
STUFF ON ALL THE BRONX OF THAT
CAREER LADDER WE'RE GOING TO
BUILD AS WELL AS NO CLOSED DOORS
SO SOME DOOR BUSTERS TO AND SOME
NONSENSE. I HEARD ON ABSOLUTELY
ABSOLUTELY AND OKAY AGAIN I JUST
WANT TO DEMONSTRATE THAT THIS IS
NOT BECAUSE I KNOW IT YOUR
AGENDA OUTLINES THIS IS WHILE
SOME CONCERNS EXPRESSED
ESPECIALLY BY RECIPIENTS OF I
JUST I STAYING WE DON'T WANT TO
LOSE OUR PROVIDERS WE WANT TO
INSURE THEM SO I JUST WANT TO
GET AND EMPHASIZE THAT THIS IS
AN EFFORT THAT IS BOTH
RECRUITING NEW HSS PROVIDERS
RETAINING THOSE THAT WE HAVEN'T
REALLY AREN'T GETTING
OPPORTUNITIES EVEN FURTHER. I
BUILD COMPETENCIES AND SKILLS
AND SPECIALIZED SKILLS FOR THEM
TO MEET THE NEEDS THAT I JUST S.
RECIPIENTS BUT ALSO FOR THOSE
WHO ARE INTERESTED IN CLIMBING
THAT LADDER THAT YOU REFERENCE
SHARE I'M REALLY PROVIDING THOSE
CLEAR PATHWAYS. FOR THEM TO DO
SO AND GO ON THEIR WAY IN TERMS
OF HEALTH CARE SO I WILL AGAIN
TURN IT OVER TO OUR ACTING
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR AT RESPONSES
TO THE QUESTIONS. IN YOUR
AGENDA. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DIRECTORS- SO. AS SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS PLEASE PROVIDE AN
UPDATE ON THE ROLE OF THAT JUST
AS YOUR PATHWAYS. WE ACTUALLY
DONE QUITE A FEW ACTIVE. WE
MEDICAL STAKEHOLDERS LAST JULY
AND SEPTEMBER TO DEFINE THE
CAREER PATHWAYS PROGRAM
DIRECTIVES. WE ALSO HELD A
PUBLIC LISTENING SESSIONS IN
DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ONE IN
JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO. UP
FOR FEEDBACK FROM I JUST AS
RECIPIENTS OF PROVIDERS REGARDS
TO. OUT WITH REGARDS TO HOW
WE'RE GOING TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROGRAM WE ASKED FOR CONCERNS-
THEIR THOUGHTS. THEY WERE VERY
WELL ATTENDED- WE'RE PLANNING
ON. ANOTHER LISTENING SESSION IN
LATE FEBRUARY OR EARLY MARCH-
THIS. FISH WERE ACTUALLY FOCUS
ON LANGUAGE ACCESS ONE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT- ARE. RECIPIENTS
OF PROVIDERS PRODUCT WHAT WAS
LANGUAGE ACCESS AND EVEN
LANGUAGE ACCESS. TO THE
LISTENING SESSIONS SO WE WANT TO
DEFINITELY TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SCHEDULE ANOTHER LISTENING
SESSION AND INCLUDE THOSE PEOPLE
IN OUR POPULATIONS THAT MAY NOT
HAVE PARTICIPATED BEFORE BECAUSE
OF LANGUAGE ACCESS. AND SO
THAT'S- REALLY WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO BE DOING AND THE- FEBRUARY
MARCH TIME- AS FAR AS- WE ARE
PURSUING CONTRACTS- A COUPLE OF
I. ONE INSTANCE SIR. WITH TO-
THE ACTUAL PATHWAYS THEMSELVES
IN THE CAREER GLADYS'S- WE WANT
TO BRING SOMEBODY WHO HAD A LOT
OF EXPERIENCE IN THIS SPACE- SO
THAT THEY CAN HELP US BUILD. OUT
THOSE AREAS OF THE PROGRAM AN
ADDITIONAL THEY WERE ALSO-
PURSUING- VENDOR ASSISTANCE WITH
CAREER COACHING- FOR PROGRAM
PARTICIPANTS- THERE ALSO CAN
HELP US WITH MARKETING AND
OUTREACH AND- HELP US WITH DATA
AND SETTING UP SOME OF THOSE
THINGS WE NEED TO PAY-
INDIVIDUAL PROVIDERS FOR
ATTENDING. THE TRAINING- WE'RE
ALSO PLANNING ON PUBLISHING A.
R. T. AND THE PROBABLY MARCH
APRIL TIMELINE FOR THIS TO COME.
SO THAT'S PART OF THE STATUTORY
FIREMEN FOR COMPETITIVE BID-
WE'RE LOOKING FOR TRAINING
VENDORS- WE- AND IT WORKS ALL OF
THE AGREE TO BE EXTRA PRIOR TO
THE IMPLEMENTATION DATE OF THE
SEPTEMBER OCTOBER TIME SH SO-
THAT'S PRETTY MUCH WHERE WE ARE
WITHOUT WE'RE ALSO PLANNING
THERE IS A PROVISION IN THE
STATUTE FOUR EIGHT EVALUATION
PERIOD IN A REPORT SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT- CONTRACTING FOR THAT
PIECE AS WELL BECAUSE WE
DEFINITELY WANT. TO GET A HOLD
OF HOW WELL THIS- PROGRAM IS
AND HOW EFFECTIVE IT IS AND ALSO
WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF WORKING
ON THE SYSTEM AUTOMATION SO- WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO EIGHT PEOPLE- THAT THEY
CAN CLAIM THEIR TIME AND THAT.
THEY ARE ABLE TO NOT ONLY GET
THEIR TIME PAID FOR THE TIME THE
INTENSE RAINY BUT ALSO THE
INCENTIVE SO THAT'S PRETTY MUCH
WHERE WE ARE AS FAR AS THE
ROLLOUT. FOR CAREER. I THINK I
THINK WE ARE YOU CAN JUST GOING
TO THE OTHER SIR A LITTLE BIT.
ABOUT WHAT THEY ARE AND IN GOOD
FOR EVERY GREAT THANK YOU SURE-
SO THE SECOND QUESTIONS RELATED
TO THE PASSWORD TOPIC AREAS AND-
THERE ARE FIVE. ARE YOU JUST AS
CAREER PATHWAYS. TO THE GENERAL
AREA WHICH IS GENERAL HEALTH AND
SAFETY AND ADULT EDUCATION. AND
THEN THREE SPECIALIZED AREAS
WHICH INCLUDE COGNITIVE
IMPAIRMENTS IN BEHAVIOR HEALTH.
COMPLEX PHYSICAL NEEDS. AND
TRANSITIONING FROM HOMELESSNESS
. I'M THESE TOPICS FOR CHOSEN AS
RESULT OF STAKEHOLDER. HELD IN-
JULY AND SEPTEMBER WITH THE
PUBLIC WITH A WITH THE
CALIFORNIA. PUBLIC AUTHORITIES
B- COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION- THE LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS- S. C. A. AND UW
EXTENDED THE SESSIONS AS WELL AS
RECIPIENTS OF PROVIDERS AND
LEGAL ADVOCATES- BOB FIVE CAREER
PATHWAYS- KIND OF. ARE SEPARATED
TO WHERE YOU HAVE THREE THAT ARE
RELATED TO I IT JUST LAST. IN
QUALITY OF CARE AND THEN YOU
HAVE THE TO GENERAL- PTHWAYS.
THAT ARE ALL RELATED TO SETTING
FOUNDATIONS AND GETTING GENERAL-
TRAINING IN AREAS LIKE AND
HEALTH AND SAFETY AND EDUCATION-
THE ANTICIPATED. THAT WE- WERE
HOPING FOR OR RECEIPT WE- WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE AND WE'RE AND
WE'RE- POSITIVE WE WILL SEE-
INCREASE QUALITY OF CARE
PROVIDERS WHO WILL HAVE BUILT
UPON THEIR KNOWLEDGE AND SKILLS
HOUSE SOMETHING SIMPLY HEARD IN. THE- IN THE LISTINGS FROM
PROVIDER ARE THERE P. OUT WHO DO
NOT FEEL- WITH PROVIDE CERTAIN
SERVICES TO THEIR RECIPIENTS OF
THEIR VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THINGS- AND SO WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE ADDRESSING
THOSE TUNES. BURNS THROUGH THIS
TRAINING- WE ALSO WANT TO. WE
ENCOURAGE MEANINGFUL
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN I JUST AS
RECIPIENTS OF THEIR PROVIDERS
AND PROVIDE SOME OF THOSE
SKILLS- FOR HELP WITH THAT.
RELATIONSHIP AND IMPROVE CARE
OUTCOMES- WE ARE IN THE- IN THE
PROCESS OF- OF CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH OUR STAKEHOLDERS ON
THIS WE'RE REALLY EXCITED ABOUT
THIS PROPOSAL. AND THE GOAL IS
REALLY TO IMPLEMENT A- EIGHT
PROGRAMS THAT IS USED BY MANY
AND IS REALLY REALLY. HOW
EFFECTIVE AT PROVIDING THE
SKILLS AND ENCOURAGING. PEOPLE
TO TAKE THOSE NEXT STEPS IF THEY
WANT TO FURTHER THEIR CAREER IN
THE HEALTHCARE FIELD OR IF THEY
JUST WANT TO. BILL BETTER ABOUT
PROVIDING SERVICES TO THEIR-
IT'S A STEP. OUR SO WERE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS WITH REGARDS TO
THAT. IT TO YOU WE'VE CONTRACTED
WITH THE VENDOR ALREADY THAT
THAT THAT HAS IDENTIFIED DID YOU
SAID WE'RE WORKING WITH A WITH A
PROGRAM THAT. THE THAT EVERYONE
REALLY LOOKS. YES I APOLOGIZE.
SO WE ARE WORKING ON- A CONTRACT
WITH THE CONSULTANTS TO HELP US
BUILD THE ACTUAL. SO THERE'S-
MULTIPLE THINGS REFUSE THAT
THERE IS WE WERE DOING EIGHT
EIGHT R. P. TO BRING ON TRAINING
VENDORS AND THEN WE HAVE A
CONSULTANT THAT'S ACTUALLY GOING
TO HELP US SET UP THE- STRUCTURE
OF THE PROGRAM WHERE WE PROVIDE
THE INFORMATION THAT IS NEEDED
FOR. PROVIDERS TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO TO GET TO
THAT OTHER CAREER- THE OTHER THE
OTHER HEALTH CARE CAREERS SO
THAT'S THE GOAL IS TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION TO PEOPLE THAT USE
THEM SO THESE ARE THE TRAINING
CLASSES THAT YOU CAN TAKE IN
THESE ARE SETTING THE
FOUNDATIONS FOR IT THIS IF YOUR
GOAL IS TO. MAKE THE NCAA OR OR
SOME TYPE OF NURSE THEN WE- BEST
CONSULTANTS GOING TO HELP US DO. THAT THE TRAINING PIECES DONE
THROUGH THE CAMPAIGN. PROCESS SO
HOPE IS TO BRING BY. ON WHO
ALREADY A STEP CORRECT. SO THE
GOAL IS NOT TO. CORRECT BUT TO
BRING. ON WHO MISSED CURRICULUM
IN THESE AREAS. LOOK AT THAT AND
THE QUESTION ON THE DID AND SO
AND THEN THAT THIS QUESTION
NUMBER THREE THIS IS HOW CAN BE
TO THESE P. THE CELLS LIKE YOUR
- IS WE'RE GOING TO PROVIDE OF
CAPACIT'E WAYS PEOPLE FEEL
BETTER ABOUT THEIR WORK. AND
THAT WILL BE A WAY TO RETAIN
THEM I MIGHT BE JUMPING TO
CONCLUSIONS. YOU KNOW THAT THAT
IS VERY VERY CLOSE YES WE DO
BELIEVE BASED ON THE FEEDBACK
AND THE EXCITEMENT FROM THE I'D
JUST AS PROVIDER COMMUNITY WHEN
WE WENT OUT AND GET THESE
LISTENING SESSIONS PEOPLE ARE
REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THESE
TRAINING. AND I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT IS A VERY DIFFICULT
AS AN AGENT SUCH PROVIDERS WHEN
YOU'RE HELPING SOMEBODY. THAT'S
REALLY. REALLY SEVERELY IMPAIR.
AND NEEDS A LOT OF US BUT I DO
PEOPLE. ARE SCARE- WHEN THEY-
THOSE IN THE- APPEAR. WHETHER
THEIR FAMILY MEMBER. FAMILY
MEMBERS. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
. FIGHTERS REALLY EMPHASIZE. WAS
HELPING THEM IN THOSE AREAS HOW
DO WE YOUR FOR PERSONAL CARE
SERVICES HOW DO WE PERFORM THESE
SERVICES IN THE STATE. AND SO
WHAT WE'RE HOPING IS BY
PROVIDING SOME OF THAT TRAINING
WE RETAIN PEOPLE BECAUSE WE'RE
KIND OF A LIMITING SOME OF THE
FAIR YEARS SEVERAL DIFFICULTIES
THAT PEOPLE HAVE. AS BEING A
PROVIDER AND THEN WE ALSO WANT
TO RECRUIT PEOPLE BY SAYING HEY
WE HAVE A WONDERFUL TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOU TO COME IF
YOU COME TO BE AND I JUST AS
PROVIDER IN THIS PROGRAM WE'RE
GOING TO PROVIDE THESE. THIS
TRAINING SPEECH TRAINING
SERVICES TO YOU SO YOU CAN
ACTUALLY BETTER YOURSELF AND IF
YOU WANT TO. PURSUE A CAREER IN
HEALTH AND HEALTH CARE FIELD YOU
CAN DO THAT AND WE'RE GOING TO
PROVIDE YOU THE INFORMATION ON
HOW TO. I WILL. IF I IF I MIGHT
SHOW ADD A CUP THINGS ONE I
WOULD JUST SAY- IS SPECIALLY-
LISTENING SESSIONS ONE OF THE
THINGS WE HEARD NUMEROUS TIMES
FROM. THE WORK FORCE WAS AT
PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO ARE
CARING FOR. A POTENTIALLY LEVEL
ON A RELATIVE OR SOMEONE ELSE
WITH DEMENTIA FOR EXAMPLE AND
JUST REALLY WANTED TO. MORE
TOOLS AND RESOURCESTO BE ABLE
TO BETTER SERVE- THAT INDIVIDUAL
AND SO THAT'S A THAT'S AN EGG AT
MORE CONCRETE EXAMPLE. I ALSO
JUST WANT TO MENTION THAT THIS
IS ANOTHER PLACE ON THE SILO
BUSTING FRAME. WHERE WE ALSO
ALSO HAVE A PARTNERSHIP HERE AND
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A NUMBER OF
OTHER AT INVESTMENTS PROPOSED A
RELATED TO THE WORK FORCE AND
ACTUALLY HEALTHCARE CAREERS AS
WELL SOCIAL WORK
EXTRATERRESTRIAL TALK TO YOU
ABOUT THE FUTURE HEARING- ABOUT
WITH OUR- SISTER DEPARTMENT
HEALTH CARE. ACCESS INFORMATION
HIS H. KILEY IS REALLY WORKING
ON THIS WITH THAT SOME OF THESE
CAREER LOUDEST- OBVIOUSLY
EXISTENCE TO WHERE WE ARE
TAPPING INTO EXISTING WE
CERTAINLY WANT TO DO THAT. BUT
WHERE WE ARE CREATING THAT NEW
PATHWAY. AT TO GET TO THAT-
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THIS IS
INTENDED TO DO SO JUST ALSO
WANTED TO NOTE THAT KIND OF
PARTNERSHIPS THAT WE'RE WORKING
ON- AND ALSO USING WITHIN THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICE. AGENCY
JOINT CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR
PARTNERS AND COLLEAGUES IN
HIGHER EDUCATION ADULT. AVERAGE
WHAT'S OUT THERE AND HOW W CAN
USE THAT AT TO FURTHER THIS
PARTICULAR. SECTOR SILO BUSTING
AT ITS FINEST JERRY SPIN OFF FOR
THE SEQUEL HAS BEEN TASTIC. LA-
ANYTHING. THANK YOU FROM THE
AREA THE ONLY THING I WOULD ADD
GIVEN THAT THE- COMMITTEE
EXPRESSED- JUST BEING AWARE OF
THE VARIOUS MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING INITIATIVES THAT ARE OUT
THERE SPIEGEL TO CROSS THE
BUDGET THIS PARTICULAR ONE I'M
DOES ADDRESS INITIATIVE WITHIN
THE MASTER PLAN FOR AGING- THAT
FLAGS BE. I'M CONSIDERATION OF
EXPANDING TRAINING PLATFORM
SPECIFICALLY DEMENTIA TRAINING-
FOR RIGHT JUST AS CARE GIVERS-
WHO ARE SEEKING BOTH CAREER
LADDER OPPORTUNITIES BUT ALSO
JUST A WAY THAT BETTER SERVE
THEIR- THEIR RECIPIENTS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. KANKAN OF FINANCE
FURTHER TO ADD AT THIS.
ARMENIANS QUESTIONS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH BURKE PAN. THE FAA YOU
IN THAT. REALLY APPRECIATE IT
THANK WHAT WHAT ARE THE
CHALLENGES ALWAYS THAT WHEN YOU
DEVELOP YOUR LETTER WORDS THAT
CAREER LADDER LEADING YOU RIGHT
AND- HOPEFULLY ONE OF THE PASSED
FOR A CAREER LADDERS NOT
NECESSARILY TO. STAND APART FROM
THE CARE OF DIFFICULT PERSON TO
BUT THEY CAN GET. LET'S SAY
HIGHER. HIGHER PAY OR OTHER
THINGS FOR HAVING HUMILIATED
MORE SKILLS SO- AND HAVE THAT
KIND OF PATH AS WELL SO- I THINK
I KNOW YOU'RE LOOKING AT THAT
AND- SO AND BUT- I ALSO HEAR
THIS TENSION WITH THE WITH THE-
RECIPIENTS THAT OF COURSE THEY
DON'T WANNA LOSE. LOSE. SOMEONE
WHO JUST- WHO- HAS BEEN TAKING
OF THEM JUST THINKING. MY THREE
CAREER LADDERS. DIFFERENT
DIRECTIONS CURLERS GAL THANK YOU
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH CIRCUMVENT
DIRECTOR JOHNSON YOU NEXT ONE'S
ISSUE NUMBER SIX. S. THANK YOU
CHAIR AND I'M GOING TO TURN IT
RIGHT OVER ADD TO THAT CURRENCY
OUR NEW CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
THAT I INTRODUCED HER. WELCOME
TERENZI. THANK YOU CHAIR EGGMAN-
AND- SENATOR AND HAPPY TO BE
HERE TODAY AND HAPPY TO BE HERE
REPRESENTING THE DEPARTMENT- AND
I'M GONNA BE TALKING TODAY
ABOUT- THE EXERCISES G. PROGRAM.
AND ANSWERING YOUR QUESTIONS- SO
ARE THE FIRST QUESTION WAS TO
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THE
PROPOSED TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
BUDGET THE SSI PROGRAM. SO WE
ARE SEEING AN INCREASE IN OUR
TOTAL FUND SPENDING FOR THE
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE- IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
THE TOTAL PROGRAM COST WAS NINE
POINT NINE BILLION DOLLARS IN
TOTAL FUN. TWO POINT NINE
BILLION OF THAT WAS GENERAL
FUND. WE ARE ANTICIPATING A
PROJECTED INCREASE TO TEN POINT
THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE WITH THREE
POINT ONE BILLION THE GENERAL
FUND. WE ARE PROJECT. A CASELOAD
DECREASED A SLIGHT ONE. RIGHT
NOW IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO OUR
CASELOAD IS ONE POINT ONE THREE
SEVEN BILLION- CALIFORNIANS. AND
WE'RE PROJECTING THAT DECREASED
JUST SLIGHTLY- ONE POINT ONE.
ZERO NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND-
CALIFORNIA SO ONE POINT NINE.
ONE SIX SIX ME- AND WE ARE
SEEING THAT THE- OVERALL
INCREASE IN SPENDING IS GOING TO
BE DRIVEN. BY A COUPLE OF
THINGS- WE WILL BE TAKING THE
FULL YEAR IMPACT. OF OUR OF FIVE
POINT NINE FEDERAL- COST OF
LIVING INCREASE. AND WE WILL BE
SEEING THE FULL IMPACT OF R.
TWENTY THREE POINT NINE FIVE
PERCENT. INCREASE IN OUR S. P.
GRANTS WILL. AGAIN WE THINK THE
LEGISLATURE FOR WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. TO MAKE
BACKGROUND INCREASE THE REALITY.
I AND WE ARE THAT- WE WILL ALSO
HAVE A HALF YOUR IMPACT OR THE
ANTICIPATED TWO POINT THREE.
PERCENT FEDERAL COLA THAT WE-
DENTISTRY WILL TAKE PLACE. NEXT
FOR THE SECOND HALF OF OUR
FISCAL YEAR- THAT IS OVERDUE FOR
QUESTION NUMBER ONE- FOR OUR-
SECOND QUESTION. THIS WAS A
QUESTION RELATED TO POTENTIALLY
LOOKING AT THE CLIENT
INVOLVEMENT IN OUR SS I SS P.
AND- WHAT RELIANCE YOU SEE
TECHNOLOGY HAVING AND HOW WE CAN
MAKE SURE PEOPLE ARE BENEFITING.
FROM THE PROGRAM THAT WE WANT
PEOPLE TO BENEFIT FROM SO I
BELIEVE THE COMMUNITIES WHERE
THE EXERCISE IS- LARGELY A
FEDERALLY RUN PROGRAM AND THE
STATE'S OUR PORTION IS REALLY
AROUND. OF FUNDING ACCESS P. AND
MAKING THE PAYMENTS- AND WE DO
WANT TO CLARIFY ONE THING THE
QUESTION ARE COUNTY THIS IS ARE
OPEN BUT THOSE ARE NOT
MINISTERS. THE S. S. I. S. B.
APPLICATIONS AND WHO INVESTORS
ALSO SIDE BUT INSTEAD IS A
SOCIAL SECURITY YOUNG OFFICERS
AND THOSE HAVE BEEN CLOSED SINCE
THE BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC-
THE LATEST WE HAVE RECEIVED WORD
FROM SOCIAL SECURITY IS THAT
THEY ARE TENTATIVELY RE OPENING
IN EARLY APRIL OF THIS YEAR. BUT
THAT DATE HAS BEEN PUSHED BACK
MORE THAN ONCE WHEN DIFFERENT
VARIANTS HAVE- HAVE BECOME
SURGES AND WE. SAW THAT RECENTLY
WITH ON- THERE ARE FEDERAL
RESOURCE OF THE- FROM S. HELP.
FACILITATE PICKING UP ADURING
THIS TIME- INCLUDING AWAY PAGE
SHE WAS. OUR PEOPLE OUR FAMILY
MEMBERS AND FRIENDS TO HELP
MULTIPLY. AND A LITTLE. OFFER IN
PERSON APPOINTMENTS- TO ADDRESS
CRITICAL NEEDS- AND WHEN CLIENTS
HAVE BEEN UNABLE TO USE AS A
STAYS AUTOMATED SYSTEM TO MEET
THAT NEED. WE DO THINK THOUGH IT
WILL BE EXTREMELY IMPORTANT BUT
THE FIELD OFFICES TO JUST BE
REAL. I WE DO HAVE SOME- DATA
RESTRICTIONS ARE ARE YOU KNOW
KNOWING WHO'S APPLYING BUT WE
ARE REALLY COMMITTED. TO MAKING
SURE WE'RE MAKING THIS PROGRAM
STRONG AND I CALIFORNIANS CAN
ACCESS- THE ONE PROGRAM I DO
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT WHICH WE'LL
TALK ABOUT MORE EXPLICITLY
WITHIN A HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAM AT NEXT
WEEK'S SENATE HEARING. BUT WE DO
HAVE OUR H. SHOP WHICH IS OUR
HOUSING AND DISABILITY ADVOCACY
PROGRAM. ON YOUR MEMBER THAT
BUDGET YOU'RE TWENTY ONE
INCLUDED AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS OF ONGOING
FUNDING FOR EACH JOB. BUT WE
ALSO START I. A TOTAL OF A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION ONE
TIME. IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO ANOTHER HUNDRED FIFTY
AND TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. OF
THAT WE CAN EXPAND THROUGH JUNE
OF TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. SO REALLY
EXCITED TO SEE ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT AND R. H. DOT PROGRAMS-
TO MAKE SURE THAT CLIENTS ARE
ABLE TO- APPLY FOR SSI AND OTHER
DISABILITY BENEFITS AND ALSO. IN
COMBINATION WITH ANY HOUSING
SUPPORT- WITHOUT BECAUSE IF
THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS ON SSI
SS PROGRAM. DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
NONCONFORMING IF THEY NEED
SOMETHING FURTHER UP THE
INTERVIEW QUESTIONS HELLO. YES
AND WE ALSO RECENTLY PUBLISHED
OUR ANALYSIS OF THE EXERCISES P.
BUDGET LAST WEEK I'M IN IN
PARTICULAR- WE FLAG THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S INTENDS TO PROVIDE
ANOTHER ASSIST BE GRANT INCREASE
IN TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR I'M
GENERAL GENERALLY ALIGNS WITH
INTENT LANGUAGE ADOPTED AND THE
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET- THAT HAD THE
SAME GOAL. I'M IN PARTICULAR ARE
UNDERSTANDING THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET IS THAT THE INTENT IS TO
INCREASE S. S. P. GRANTS SO THAT
THE TOTAL EXERCISES PETE GRANT
I'M REFLECT PRE RECESSION LEVELS
I'M IT'S STILL UNCLEAR TO US
EXACTLY WHAT PRE RECESSION
LEVELS NEED- BUT IT FOR EXAMPLE
IF WE ASSUME THAT IT MEANS
JANUARY TWO THOUSAND NINE- WHICH
WAS GENERALLY THE YEAR AND
MONTHS BEFORE WE STARTED- BUT
BEFORE THERE WERE MULTIPLE
REDUCTIONS TO THE S. S. P. GREEN
INCREASED. THEN THE- INTENDED AS
IS P. GRANT INCREASE IN TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR WOULD BE MORE
THAN ENOUGH TO MEET THAT GOAL.
HOWEVER OVERALL WE BELIEVE THAT
ALTERNATELY WHATEVER ASSIST HE
GRANT INCREASES ADOPTED SHOULD
REALLY REFLECT THE LEGISLATURE
SCHOOLS WHERE DOES THE
LEGISLATURE OPENLY WHAT
ULTIMATELY WANT SIZES BE GRANTS
TO BE ACT- AND OVER WHAT TIME
PERIOD I'M SO IN AREN'T BY NOR
ADDITIONAL BUDGET ANALYSIS WE
JUST LAID OUT. POSSIBLE EXAMPLES
OF ALTERNATIVE GRANT GOALS SUCH
AS INCREASING- S. SIZES P.
GRANTS FOR INDIVIDUALS 2100% OF
THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL GIVEN
THAT COUPLES GRANTS IN THE
ESTATE IS P. PROGRAM- FALL ABOVE
THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL
ANOTHER EXAMPLE THAT WE INCLUDE
IN OUR POST IS- AT RESTORING THE
PURCHASING POWER THAT'S BEEN
LOST SINCE TWO THOUSAND NINE- TO
ACCOUNT FOR INFLATION- AND IN
OUR POST WE LAID OUT- VARIOUS
COST ESTIMATES ASSOCIATED WITH
THOSE. IMPOSSIBLE GOALS I'M ONCE
THE LEGISLATURE. THE SPECIFIC AS
PEOPLE'S COULD THAT CAN OVER
TIME IT WOULD LIKE TO IN THOSE
CALL IT COULD BE A FROM YEAR-
BUT ALSO CAN- PROVIDE. ANNUAL
COLD AND A WAY TO MAKE. THE
DOLLAR VALUE- OF THE GRANTS ONCE
YOU ACHIEVE YOUR GOAL- OVERALL
THOUGH AND THERE'S ALSO THAT
THEY NEED TO CONSIDER BALANCING-
AND THE LONG TERM COSTS. OF AS
IS BE GREAT INCREASES IN COAL
ONCE I'M WITH THE ABILITY TO
SUSTAIN. THOSE COSTS IN THE
FUTURE YEARS. BY OVERALL I WE
WOULD JUST THAT- ONE A PROJECT.
S. P. GRANT INCREASE IS IT IS
DECIDED UPON I'M THE LEGISLATURE
MAY ALSO WANT TO CONSIDER
LOOKING BACK AT THE- STATUTORY
LANGUAGE AROUND THE- TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR S. B. GRANT
AND INCREASE INTENT LANGUAGE-
JUST BECAUSE WHILE IT DOES
PROVIDE THAT SPECIFIC START DATE
OF TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR. THE
LANGUAGE ISN'T NECESSARILY VERY
TIGHT WHEN IT COMES TO BE EXACT
GRANT AMOUNT- AS A UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT THE TWENTY FOUR THAT THE
APPROXIMATELY 24% RATE INCREASE
THAT- IS INTENDED TO BE PROVIDED
IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY FOUR IS AN
ESTIMATE. I'M SO TO THE EXTENT
THAT THAT SUBJECT TO CHANGE- THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO CONSIDER
DOES IT WANT TO LOCK IN A
CERTAIN GRANT AMOUNT RIGHT NOW
THAT WOULD BE PROVIDED I'M IN
FUTURE YEAR. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. DOCTOR JOHNSON DO
YOU HAVE ANY COMMENT ABOUT. DID
YOU MEAN PRE RECESSION TWO
THOUSAND NINE OR DO WE KNOW.
WHAT WE MEAN. S. ONE MAYBE ASK
MY CALLED THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IF THEY WANNA. AT IN
HERE THANK YOU THANKS THINK
EXPLANATION MUCH LIKE HE HAD
MENTIONED- WATER THAT WE DID
NEED THAT RECESSION. IN TOTAL.
MUGGLES. THE TO HELP TWO
THOUSAND NINE IN TOTAL YOU MEAN
CRACKS OKAY. OKAY THANK YOU
THANK AND WILL WILL WE WILL LOOK
AT IN DETAIL ALL THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND SEE WHAT
DIRECTION IT- WE WANT TO GO.
TOGETHER DR GRANT. OKAY OKAY
DIRECTOR JOHNSON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NICE TO SEE YOU TODAY I
THINK THAT'S IT FOR YOU AND I
THINK WE'RE MOVING ON TO THE
NEXT DEPARTMENT. AND WE HAVE
HERE. WE HAVE A PS. YES IT'S
STILL WITH US. OKAY WELL WHAT.
IS YOUR IF I MIGHT SURE I'M JUST
LOVE TO- JUST TAKE A MOMENT AS I
HAVE THE MICROPHONE HERE TO
CONFIRM ON ISSUE FOR THAT WE
WILL IN FACT BE ABLE TO
REINSTATE THE EMERGENCY PROVIDER
BACKUP SYSTEM AND HAVE AT TRYING
TO WORK ON THAT GAP AT LEAST
REGION SO JUST WANTED TO CONFIRM
THAT FROM A PRIOR COMMENTS OKAY
CONTESTING. I AM CLOUT PROUD TO
INTRODUCE YOU CAN RUTLEDGE WHO
AS A LEADER EVER ADOPT ACTIVE
SERVICES AND HAS JUST BEEN DONE
DOING A PHENOMENAL JOB ON THE
COLLABORATION BOTH A MASTER PLAN
ON AGING AS YOU HEARD EARLIER IN
YOUR COMMENTS TODAY THAT DAY.
THE MASTERMINDS BEHIND THE NEWLY
DEVELOPED ELDER DISABILITY
JUSTICE COORDINATING COUNCIL AND
JUST REALLY WANT TO CREATE
LOOKED AT HER WORK WE'RE GLAD TO
SEE EXPANDED ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES AND AGAIN THE
CONNECTIONS TO HOUSING THE CASE
MANAGEMENT EXPANSION- IT TO DO
MORE HERE SO I WILL TURN IT OVER
TO CAN RATLEDGE TO ANSWER THE
QUESTIONS IN YOUR GENDER. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WELCOME CAMPAIGN
THANK YOU DIRECTOR JOHNSON- GET
AFTERNOON I'D SURE EGGMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- KIM
RUTLEDGE ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES PROGRAM LIAISON WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES- I'M JUST GOING TO GO
DIRECTLY INTO THE QUESTION THAT
WERE. INCLUDED IN THE AGENDA
TODAY- WHICH STARTS WITH AN
OVERVIEW OF THE BUDGET FOR THE A
TF PROGRAM INCLUDING FEDERAL
COVERED NINETEEN REALLY FINDING
AND HOW IT WOULD BE IS- SO. FOR
THAT- BRIEF OVERVIEW- AGE BUT-
THIS PROGRAM IS PREDOMINATELY
FUNDED THE REAL TWENTY.
REALIGNED THROUGH THE- SERVICES
HOW- HOW. THE BUDGET ACT TWENTY
ONE. DID GIVE A SEVEN MILLION
DOLLAR ST JOHN FUND. AND
ALLOCATE. WHEN IT. OF THE-
PROGRAM. AND THAT X.
PREDOMINATELY THE BIGGEST PIECE
OF THAT IS TO ENABLE THE APS
PROGRAM- YOU SERVE INDIVIDUALS
THAT OUR ELDERS BETWEEN THE AGE
OF SIXTY AND SIXTY FOUR- PRIOR
TO JANUARY FIRST. TWENTY TWENTY
TWO- THE DEFINITION OF OLDER FOR
PURPOSES OF APIA. WITH AGES
SIXTY FIVE AND OVER HOWEVER THE
BUDGET AX CHANGE THAT. AGE SIXTY
AND OVER- IN ORDER FOR A DEATH
AGE SIXTY TO SIXTY FOUR
POPULATION TO BE ABLE TO BE
SERVED. BY OTHER OLDER AMERICANS
ACT PROGRAM AND OTHER SENIOR
SERVICE THAT- AS OF THE SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLARS THE GENERAL FUND
ONGOING ALLOCATION- IT IS GOING
TO WIN ABEL COUNTY APS PROGRAM.
TO HIRE ADDITIONAL STAFF AND
PROVIDE LONGER TERM CASE
MANAGEMENT- AFFORD THESE COMPLEX
CASES IN THIS AGE RANGE- ARE THE
BUDGET HAS ALSO EXPANDED ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAM. TO INCLUDE
HOUSING REPRESENTATIVES AND
COUNTY HSS AGENCY EMPLOYED.
MANDATED REPORTERS. AND FINALLY
AND THE ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
ALSO. REQUIRED PDF DEVELOP THE
STATE WITH THE WORK THAT FLORIDA
FEASIBILITY AT EIGHT WIDE AUTUMN
EIGHT CASE MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
DATA. THE STAFF AND WE WILL TALK
ON THAT- FURTHER DOWN IN THE
CLASS. HE IN ADDITION TO-
REALIGNMENT AND ARE SEVENTY NINE
DOLLARS THE GENERAL FUND- LAST
YEAR. EFF RECEIVE NINE POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
FUNDING- OF FOUR APR FOUR CO
THAT NNETEEN REALLY- THIS WAS
SPENDING THAT WAS DISTRIBUTED TO
APS PROGRAMS IN ALL FIFTY
STATES. IN ORDER TO ADDRESS GAPS
THAT CAME OUT FOR THE SECOND
SERVICES PROGRAM DURING THE
COMING NINETEENTH AND DONE THAT-
IN CALIFORNIA. WHAT WE ARE DOING. WITH THIS MONEY IS. IT WAS ALL
DISTRIBUTED EACH COW IF YOU
PROGRAM BASED ON- AND FORMULA HE
WE SEE AND OPENED. AND COUNTY
VENTURA TO USE THAT- FOR DIRECT
SERVICES FOR ATS CLIENTS THAT
COULD INCLUDE- EMERGENCY HOUSING
THAT IS NOT COVERED THROUGH ANY
OF OUR OTHER HOUSING PROGRAMS.
SUPPLEMENTAL NUTRITION FOR- ANY
KIND OF EMERGENCY SITUATION THAT
IS COVERED RELATED THAT IS NOT
COVERED THROUGH ANY OF OUR
NUTRITION PROGRAM. SUPPLEMENTING
THE COST OF TRANSPORTATION FOR
APS CLIENT- THE X. CONTINUE TO
EXPAND- FOR APS CLIENT HEALTH
NEEDS. SO THAT WAS WORKING WITH-PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES AND WITH
OTHERS TO BE ABLE TO DO HOME
VISITS OR ADDRESS- HEALTH
DISPARITIES THAT HAPPENED WHILE
INDIVIDUALS MORE. ISOLATED
DURING THE CAN DOWN THAT. HE AND
ALL TWEET YOUR NOW NEED THE-
FOR- FOR THAT AS AS WORK- IN
ADDITION TO THAT I FOR ME DOLLAR
THAT WE FOR HUNDRED REALLY. ATF
ALSO A POINT NINE DOLLARS AND
ONE FIVE COMEDIAN RED PLAY ASK
HE AND I THAT MONEY WAS VERY
SIMILAR. HE AS THE SERVICE DAY
HOWEVER WITH THE CODES- FOR
EVERY THAT WE OFFER IT HAS TO
HAVE A SHOT HI YOU CLIENTS THAT
WERE IMPACT BY THE- WHERE ALLIED
WITH THE ARKANSAS. DOES OUR
LITTLE BLOCK. SO FROM THE A
POINT SIX MILLION HI OF THOSE
WORDS. DIRECTLY YOU CAN. TODAY
HE CAN. TO DO THE ACT. THAT
WORKED. GEARING UP WITH A CO
BAND- AND THEN THE OTHER HALF OF
THE FUNDING HAS BEEN FOR A- OF
DIFFERENT DAY- STATES WERE
ENCOURAGED BY FEDERAL. YOU
EXPAND INTO OTHER PROGRAM. SO
THE BIG PROJECT THAT WE ARE
DOING WITH THE OTHER HALF OF THE
FUNDING IS- A CONTRACT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIAL WORK EDUCATION
CENTER. TO CONTINUE AND EXPAND
OUR REGIONAL TO YOUR FILE IT
TIGHTENED AND TRAINING PROGRAM
FOR MASTER'S OF SOCIAL WORK
DIDN'T MANAGE TO WORKING WITHIN
APS PROGRAMS- WE HAD A SMALL
PILOT. IN THE BAY AREA OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS TO INCREASE. THE
APS. STAFFING AND TRAINING THIS
WAS MODELED AFTER THE COMPLEX
PROGRAM THAT IS CURRENTLY USED
IN CHILD WELFARE- WHERE MSW
STUDENTS WERE INTERESTED IN
WORKING IN CHILD WELFARE CAN.
AND HOW THEIR EDUCATION PAID FOR
IN EXCHANGE FOR TWO YEAR OF
SERVICE AND CHILD WELFARE MONEY
MODEL THIS AFTER THAT WE HAD AND
DIDN'T SUCCESSFULLY GOT THERE
ARE PILOT. OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS AND SO WE'RE EXCITED TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE THE OTHER. SOME OF
THIS MONEY THROUGH THE AMERICAN
RESCUE ACT AND BANS ABOUT.
FURTHER BUT WE ARE- WORK WITH
NATIONAL ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES ASSOCIATION TO PUT
TOGETHER A PUBLIC AWARENESS
CAMPAIGN- AROUND ELDER JUSTICE
AND AROUND THE BILL PROTECTIVE
SERVICES. WITH SOME OF THE
SPENDING. AS WELL. WE ARE
ANTICIPATING A ANOTHER ROUND OF
THE RECORD PLAN AFTER. THIS IS A
TO AND HE EIGHT PROGRAM IN THE
OF TWENTY ONE TWO. AND IN A DISH
THE ONLY A THING THAT WANNA JIM
THE ATM BUDGET. IS THAT B. L.
POINT FVE MILLION A THE EVENT
OF THE LAST THREE AND YEARS OUR
API TRAINING. AT FIVE. ON JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY YEAH. THANK YOU
BIRTHER HARD COURSE I LOVE THE
SOCIAL WORK WITH APS M. A
PROGRAM. THAT DID YOU DID YOU
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE CASE
NUMBER IS GOING DOWN DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND TO WHAT DO YOU
ATTRIBUTE THAT IN. HOUSE MAKING
SURE PEOPLE ARE SAFE. WE DID.
SEE A DROP. IN THE CAN DOWN A
AND REPORTS RECEIVED ON CASES
OPEN FOR ATS- HOWEVER WE HAVE
BEEN TRACKING THAT FAIRLY
CLOSELY OVER SINCE THE BEGINNING
A PANDEMIC. AND WHAT WE HAVE
SEEN IS DURING PANDEMICS URGES
WE SEE DROPPING CASES AND THEN
WHEN. THINGS START TO OPEN BACK
UP AGAIN WE SEE THE CASE WITH
THE BACK UP AND THE REASON THAT
WE BELIEVE THIS IS HAPPENING. IS
BECAUSE THE WAY THAT THE
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE REACHED ATS
IT'S REAL- INTERACTION WITH
MANDATED REPORTERS. AND WE KNOW
THAT THIS POPULATION WAS NOT
GOING TO DOCTOR'S APPOINTMENTS
THEY WERE NOT- HAVING THE
INTERACTION AND THE COMMUNITY
THEY WERE NOT GOING TO COMMUNITY
SERVICES. WHERE ABUSE CAN BE
IDENTIFIED AS QUICKLY. SO WE ARE
SEEING THOSE CASES. WHEN I'M.
NINE K. FOUR NUMBERS FOR TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND I THINK
THE BEST WAY THAT WHEN I LOOK AT
THOSE NUMBERS I SEE THAT ARE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE NUMBERS
NATURAL TWENTY NINETEEN NUMBERS
A LITTLE BIT MORE. WITH THAT
DIFFERENT TWENTY TWENTY AND YOU
SEE A LITTLE DEVON THAT IN HALF
OVER THE SUMMER OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WHEN THERE WAS- THE DOLPHINS
BIRDS- A LITTLE BIT OF A JOB
AGAIN. AND WE REALLY DO THINK
THAT THAT IS BECAUSE THERE IS
THAT LACK OF INTERACTION WITH
MANDATED REPORTER WINDING DOWN
OR SHUT DOWN. THE YOU THE
DEPARTMENT OF. DO YOU HAVE
ANYTHING. NANKANA FINANCE
NOTHING FURTHER TO ADD AT THIS
TIME EACH ANSWERING QUESTIONS
LMAO. AND WE'RE STILL COMPLETING
OUR TECHNICAL REVIEW OF THE
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL RELATED
TO IT YES I WILL PROVIDE ANY
UPDATED COMMENTS TO THE
COMMITTEE WANTS TO BE COMPLETED.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH TALK TO
PAN AM THING ON THIS. OKAY OKAY-
DIRECTOR JOHNSON NOW I THINK
IT'S TIME FOR US TO SAY GOODBYE
WE APPRECIATE WE APPRECIATE
DEPARTMENTS WORK. AND AS NOT
THAT IT'S IN YOUR JURISDICTION
BUT AS YOU WENT OVER ALL THE
DEPARTMENT YOU CAN CERTAINLY SEE
HOW THEY FIT IN. ALL TO THE
MASTER PLAN ON AGING AND NOT
GOALS SO LET'S KEEP ON BUSTED
DOWN THOSE SILOS AND WE WILL.
TURN OVER NOW TO DIRECTOR- KEVIN
GAME BUT- ST APARTMENT. OKAY I
NEED. EXPAND AND SO. OKAY THEY
WOULD SAY HOW DID AND KEEP. YEAH
I AGAIN JUST TO RECORD THE
CROSSED YOU TO CAROLINE REALLY
DE AS SERVE THE LIFE AND JACK AS
YOU KNOW I HAVE EVERY COMPONENT
OF OUR PROGRAMS WHETHER THEY BE
A CHILD CARE AND DVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS CHILDREN'S RESIDENTIAL
OR I DON'T SENIOR CARE HAVE
CERTAINLY BEEN IMPACTED BY THE
PANDEMIC AND- SO ARE GRATEFUL
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TALK
ABOUT THE STRATEGIES THAT WE CAN
PLAY TOGETHER- THAT WAYS IN
WHICH WE WORK TO ASH INSURE
THAT. OUR RESIDENTS AT THESE
THEIR HOMES OUT WERE SAFE FOR
THEM- AND IN OUR PLANS GOING
FORWARD SO I WILL NOW TURN IT
OVER TO DEPUTY DIRECTOR KEVIN.
GAINES WELCOME TO BE DIRECTOR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU WELL I'LL GO
AHEAD AND JUST- KEVIN GAINS-
APARTMENT- NEED CARE LICENSING
DIVISION. I'LL JUST GO AHEAD AND
LAUNCH INTO OUR RESPONSES TO THE
QUESTIONS THAT ARE PROVIDED TO
GET CHECKED- AS FAR AS AN
OVERVIEW OF THE PROPOSED TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE BUDGET FOR CCL.
I'LL GO AHEAD AND DESCRIBE- THE
LIMITED AMOUNT OF FUNDING
OBLIGATIONS THAT WERE THAT WERE
PROPOSING- OVERALL OUR- OUR
GOALS AGGREGATE BUDGET FOR THE
DIVISION IS JUST UNDER ONE
HUNDRED NINETY SIX MILLION. ON
TO COVER THE ACTIVITIES OF. ONE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED SIXTY
THREE- STAFF- HE- YOU HAVE TO
PROPOSALS BEFORE YOU. ARE ONE OF
THEM IS THE EXPANSION OF A OF A
GREAT PROGRAM THAT INVOLVES THE
- EXTREME- OF NURSES EVALUATORS
ARE WHO PROVIDE CONSULTATION TO-
AT THE LICENSING PROGRAM STAFF
REGIONAL OFFICES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE ANSEL LICENSEES ON
OCCASION. ON ONE AREAS- ASPECTS
OF HEALTH AND SAFETY ACT OF THAT
THAT FIND THEIR WAY INTO
INVESTIGATIONS THAT ANNUAL
INSPECTIONS- INCLUDING-
CONSULTATION ON ON THAT THAT.
THAT THE- THAT HELPS WITH THE
BEST. AND THE AND IN A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT AREAS- HE HAD A
DURATION- DELAYED MEDICAL
TREATMENT- BODILY INJURIES OR
HOSPITALIZATIONS- INFECTION
CONTROL QUESTIONS MAY BECOME
EXTREMELY USEFUL ON DURING THE
COURSE OF ENDEMIC AND AN HOUR-
IMPRESSION CONTROL PROCEDURES
ESPECIALLY WHERE IT RELATES TO
IT DON'T SENIOR PARK. ON THE
THAT THE PROPOSAL SEEKS TO
EXPAND- THE- THE NUMBER CHANGE
FROM ONE TO TELL YOU IN ORDER TO
MEET. INCREASING DEMAND WE GET
ALL THE SENIOR CARE PROGRAM BUT
ALSO TO EXPAND- BILLS- SAME
SERVICES TO THE CHILDREN'S
RESIDENTIAL PROGRAM AND TO TRY
OUT. SO OF HUGE BENEFIT THAT
WE'RE GETTING FROM OUR- OUR
NURSES VALUE WAITERS WOULD LIKE-
ON. ALL THREE PROGRAMS. THE
OTHER CRITICAL THAT. IS
IMPLEMENTATION OF TO- RELATED TO
SENATE BILL ACOUSTIC FOUR NOVELS
ENACTED THIS YEAR R. REQUIRES
THE DEPARTMENT SAID TO MAKE SOME
CHANGES TO BE OUR TO THE ARRAY
OF- EXEMPTIONS- TO THE
POSSIBILITY OF- KURDS EXEMPTIONS
- AVAILABLE TO RELATIVES HERE.
AND SO IN ORDER TO- IN-
IMPLEMENT THAT PROGRAM- THERE'S
SOME INCREASED WORKLOAD THAT
INCLUDES REPORTING REQUIREMENTS-
SYSTEM ENHANCEMENTS AND OTHER
ELEMENTS THAT WOULD. REQUIRE. A
TEAM OF PEOPLE TO ACT. I'LL GO
AHEAD AND UNLESS THERE ARE
QUESTIONS I'LL GO AHEAD TO THE
SECOND QUESTION- WHICH IS- AN
UPDATE. OF THE ROLLOUT OF OUR
CHAIR INSPECTIONS WILL- THERE
WAS A QUESTION REGARDING- WHEN
WE'RE EXPECTING TO IMPLEMENT FOR
ALL- GRANTS. AND SO AS BUSINESS
AS THIS COMMITTEE KNOWS I
IMAGINE- THEY'D BE- HE COMMUNITY
CARE LICENSING DIVISION IS.
SPLITTING INTO THREE PRIMARY
PROGRAM CLUSTERS THE CHILD CARE
PROGRAMS CHILDREN'S RESIDENTIAL
PROGRAM AND THE ADULTS SENIOR
CARE PROGRAM ALL THREE PROGRAMS
HAVE IMPLEMENTED AT LEAST IN
PART ON ON IN IN PERSON FACILITY
INSPECTIONS USING WHAT WE CALL
COMPLIANCE AND REGULATORY
ENFORCEMENT WORK HERE TO. ON THE
CHILD CARE PROGRAM BEGAN USING
THEIR FULL SLATE OF A CARE TOOLS
FOR ANNUAL INSPECTION. BACULUM
ON NOVEMBER FIRST OF LAST YEAR.
AND IS SOON TO LAUNCH A-
RELICENSING TOOLS AS WELL IN THE
EXPECT THAT TO HAPPEN MARCELLO
SHE- IT SHOWS RESIDENTIAL
PROGRAM. AND ANNUAL INSPECTIONS-
USING THE CARE TOOLS FOR I LOVE
THAT THE NINETEEN CATEGORIES- OF
PROGRAMS. BACK ON JULY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND WE EXPECT
TO IMPLEMENT THE REST OF THE
WORLD- THE CHILDREN'S
RESIDENTIAL PROGRAMS WITH YOUR
TOOLS- ROUND SUMMER JULY. YEAH
OUR HEARTS ARE. THAT'S WHERE
DOES SENIOR CARE PROGRAMS THEY
ARE IMPLEMENTING- INSPECTION OF
PORTION OF. ON THE ONE THAT IS
SPECIFICALLY DEDICATED TO YOU.
ACTUALLY CONTROL. NO SECRETS
THIS BODY BACK THE- AT THE END
AND IT HAS- PROVIDED A GREATER
RISK IN A GREATER IMPACT IN OUR
DON'T SENIOR COMMUNITIES AND SO
WHILE THE- WHILE THE OTHER
PROGRAMS HAVE RECEDED FOR WAR ON
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE FULL
SLATED CARE. TOOLS WE'RE
LIMITING OUR- IN. OF THE CARE
CENTER WITHIN ADULT AND SENIOR
ONTARIO INSPECTIONS ARE USING BE
INSPECTION CONTROL DOMAIN WHICH
IS FAIRLY EXPENSIVE UNIT IN
ITSELF. OFF UNTIL WE DETERMINED
THAT- THAT INSPECTIONS ARE NO
LONGER NEEDED TO SPECIFICALLY
FOCUS ON PROBABLY NINETEEN AN
INSPECTION. OUR DAUGHTER BY THE
NINE DAYS- AND THERE. THE THIRD
QUESTION WAS ABOUT- THEY THE
INCREASE IN THE- THE BACKLOG-
THERE THERE HAS BEEN A WHOLE LOT
OF SENSE I GUESS PRIOR TO THE-
TO THE ONSET OF THE PANDEMIC-
ON. A RISE IN THE BACKLOG OF
THOSE COMPLAINTS ESPECIALLY THE
ONES THAT THAT ARE PENDING FOR
MORE THAN NINETY DAYS- I LIKE TO
EXPRESS TO YOU WHAT HAS
CONTRIBUTED TO THAT AND- OUR
GOALS- ACTION PLAN. TO CORRECT.
PLEASE I WANTED TO STAY WITH
WITH. THE STATE THAT- IN
REGARDLESS OF THE OF THE SIZE OF
BACK BACKLOG ON HEALTH AND
SAFETY IS ALWAYS PROTECTED I- BY
OUR INITIAL- INVESTIGATION.
EVERY COMPLAINT WITHIN TEN DAYS
REGARDLESS OF THE TIME IT TAKES
TO CLOSE THOSE COMPLAINTS. SO ON
ESPECIALLY WHERE IMMEDIATE
CONCERNS OF HEALTH AND SAFETY
OUR PARENTS- D. D. EITHER
THROUGH OUR A LICENSING PROGRAM
ANALYST STAFF OR THROUGH OUR
DEDICATED- INVESTIGATIONS- D. D.
GET TO EVERY INITIAL EVERY
COMPLAINT- WITHIN TEN. THAT'S
OUR- I ALSO LIKE TO ADD THAT ON
THE ROUTE HAND. REGARDLESS PRIOR
ONE AND PRIORITY TWO FROM. WE
HAVE WE ORGANIZED AND SET OF A-
TRIAGE THEM ORDER PRIORITY CAN.
ARE YOU TO- BE- I TO DIRECTLY TO
HELL AND SAFETY. RECALL OR OR
MOTIONAL OR OR SECTION
ALLEGATIONS- WITH PRIORITY
THIRTY FOUR- LET THAN THAT MONTH
BEING LESS AGREE THAT IN THOSE
THEIR- ON BUT PRIOR ONE AND
PRIORITY TWO COMPLAINTS ON. ALL
COMPOUND CONTINUE THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC TO BE INVESTIGATED
FIRST AND TO- AT WITH WITH IN
PERSON INSPECTIONS AND
INVESTIGATIONS. INITIATED BY OUR
INVESTIGATION. AND THEN STOP
HAPPENING RIGHT AND- NOW AS
COMPLAIN WERE IS PART OF OUR
ROUTINE. ON ROUTINE SLOW SERVE.
ON THEM WORK WELL LOT NETWORK IS
OKAY WHEN- I BROWN SHOULD. GET
RECOGNITION AND- HELLO YOU KNOW
THAT WE NEED YEAH OF Y. OTHER
NATURAL. MY WRITING AND NEEDED
HELP AND SAFETY ISSUES NOT ARE
OF THE- ON OF THE IMPACTS THAT.
WORSE TIME OF LEGAL THAT IT TAKE
YOU ON TRIAGE TO HIRE PRIORITY
ISSUE. AND THEN HAS BEEN OF
PARTICULAR- IN TO OUR- YOU ARE
IN THAT. B. YEAH B. LEVEL OF
DROUGHT OFF YOUR IT'S ONE ONE
NINE WITH THE LEAST UPSURGE-
STARTING BACK OKAY AND HOPEFULLY
WORK THE OTHER SIDE OF NOW BUT
DURING TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE WERE
ABLE TO READJUST OUR- READ THE
RIGHT BACK INTO. OUR OUR TO
PRACTICE- OF TRIAGING AND
MANAGING OUR COMPLAINT WORK
DURING THAT YEAH JUST LET. ME
SEE A DECREASE IN THE AVERAGE
NUMBER PLATES- BACK. GONE OVER-
OVER THAT'S- THE VASELINE. OKAY
IN THE NUMBER OF. RIGHT NOW OVER
THE MONEY IN A ROW IN AVERAGE-
READ TEN PER LINE INTO TWENTY TO
AN AVERAGE OF HUNDRED FORTY
THREE MONTH IN THE YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY. TO SAY THAT NINETY DAYS
BACK UP THAT'S THAT'S JUST FOR.
COMPLICATED CASES THAT YOU'RE
CLOSING BUT EVERYBODY'S BEEN
ASSISTED TRIAGE WITHIN THE FIRST
TEN DAYS. YES MASTER. YES UPON
AS FAR AS- ON YOU YOU TALK ABOUT
THOSE OF THOSE HIGH PRIORITY
COMPLAINTS- PRIORITIES ONE IN
JAIL. AGAIN THOSE ARE REFERRED-
GENERALLY TO OUR INVESTIGATION
BRANCH AND ONE ANOTHER A PIECE
OF POSITIVE NEWS IS THAT WE.
NEED IT THE- HE'S IN THE AVERAGE
TIME FOR OF THOSE- OF THOSE OF
PRIORITY ONE AND A THREE
COMPLAINTS DIG UNDER NINE OF
EIGHTY SEVEN. AS OUT OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AS FAR AS AM BUT WE
DO REALIZE THAT THERE IS A
CONTINUING PROBLEM THAT NEEDS.
TO MANAGE TO NOTWITHSTANDING
OUR- OUR- PRIORITIZATION SO WE
DO HAVE A PLAN IN PLACE TO- SAID
BAR KNOCKING AWAY AT AT AT SOME
OF THAT- GROWTH IN IN. OUR
COMPLAINTS THAT ARE H. PASSED
NINETY DAY OFF FIRST OFF. ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO
DO THIS TO YOU YESTERDAY. TAKE A
LOW HANGING FRUIT FARMS SO I'M
THAT THERE NEEDS. ARE OUR- IN IN
FOR PRIORITY BUCKETS ARE YOU
WANTING TO BE THE MEDIA
IMMEDIATE HEALTH AND SAFETY
ISSUES. ON ON. THIRTY IN THE
RAIN FOR BEING- LOWER LEVEL
ISSUES LIKE PRIORITY THREE BILLS
THAT WOULD BE. EMOTIONAL VERBAL
VERBAL ASSAULT ON BETWEEN
LICENSE AND- RESIDENT OR BETWEEN
THE REST. ARE YOU FOR WOULD
SOMETHING. MINOR INVOLVING
PHYSICAL. PLANT FOR EXAMPLE
ABOUT THE- DURING THE COURSE OF
INSPECTION. SO WHAT WE WILL TO
DO IS FOR- ON THEM HI PRIORITY
ONLY SOME OF THE THREE WAR OFF
OF THE TAPE BECAUSE THEY CON.
ABOUT EIGHTY PER OF THE
COMPLAINT TRACK THAT'S THAT'S
NOT AND SO ON WE WOULD LIKE TO.
PROVIDE SOME ADMINISTRATIVE-
PULLS IN THE MINISTRY- STAFF
WORK TO GET AS MANY OF THOSE-
LOWER LEVEL- EMPLOYEES- IN AND
PUT THEM IN THE COMPLETE BOX.
AND WE WILL ALSO PROPOSE TO
INITIATE A PILOT- BACK SHOWS
SOME PROMISE IN PREVIOUS YEARS
WHAT A SPANIEL AND PILOTS IN
HOUSE. HAVE DEDICATED STAFF IN
SOME OF THE LARGER TRAFFIC ALL
REGIONAL OFFICES ON TO
INVESTIGATE COMPLAINTS AS A
SPECIALIZED ASSIGNMENTS. AS
OPPOSED TO HANDLING. YOU KNOW OF
LIFE TASKS THAT ARE. A SIGN- TO
LIFE PROGRAM. HELLO FROM. ANNUAL
INSPECTION TO TWO OUTLOOK- A
SPECIAL MAY GET A LITTLE BIT- A
TRUCK. A LITTLE BIT MORE LEEWAY
IN TERMS- BEING ABLE TO ACCESS
ALL DOWN ON THE RIGHT TRACK. AND
THANK THOSE ARE ALL THE THAT WE
NOT I'M I'M HAPPY TO TAKE A
QUESTION THAT YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO BE DIRECTOR. OF
LMAO DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS ANGELA SHORT
WITH THE L. A. O. JUST A BRIEF
COMMENT THAT WE'VE REVIEWED CCL
SUCH A CHANGE PROPOSALS AND
DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS TO RAISE
THE LEGISLATURE AT THISTIME THE
PROPOSAL SEEM REASONABLE- GIVENS
UCL'S ONGOING WORKLOAD AS WELL
AS THE NEW REQUIREMENTS OF SB
THREE FIFTY FOUR. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DEPARTMENT
FINANCED YOU HAVE ANYTHING THAT
YOU'D LIKE TO ADD. HI GABY ST
TOWARD DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
NOTHING TO ADD THANK YOU CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- OKAY DR
PANDE OF ANYTHING OKAY. THE VERY
THOROUGH OKAY. THIRTY JOHNSON IS
THAT IT NOW MIKE. IT IS OFFERING
. THANK YOU SO MUCH OKAY THANK
YOU ALL VERY MCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS HAS BEEN VERY
APPRECIATED I APPRECIATE VERY
MUCH OF THE WORK YOU DO AND THE
DEDICATION AND THE SILO BUSTING
AND WE'RE GONNA GET SOME GOOD.
GOOD OUTFITS TO GO ALONG WITH IT
. OKAY AND NOW I BELIEVE WE WILL
THE MODERATOR THERE. LET'S SEE
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE IN THE QUEUE
FOR PUBLIC COMMENTS. MODERATOR
YOU THERE. BSNL IN GERMAN IT
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENTS PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. IN ONE ZERO FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT AT MODERATE Q.
TAYLOR HOW HOW MUCH HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE IN THE QUEUE AND I
WILL WANT TO REMIND PEOPLE THAT
YOU HAVE. ONE MINUTE TO EXPRESS
YOUR CONCERNS AND INPUT TO US
AND IF YOU HAVE LONGER THAN THAT
WERE INTERESTED IN HEARING YOUR
POSITIONS AND WOULD ENCOURAGE
YOU TO CALL EMAIL OR CONTACT OUR
COMMITTEE STAFF WITH ANYTHING
ADDITIONAL A MODERN HOW MANY
PEOPLE DO WE HAVE IN THE QUEUE
RIGHT NOW. AT THE TIME WE HAVE
THIRTEEN IN THE QUEUE OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FIRST COLOR PLEASE
. BUT WE'LL START WITH LINE
TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
COUNTIES UNDER LIMIT ALL OF THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION. MEETING IN A NUMBER
OF CO SPONSORS ARE SEEKING FIVE
MILLION GENERAL FUND TO CONTINUE
THE HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES TRAINING WAS
ALSO TRAINED PUBLIC GUARDIAN
STAFF AND THE PROGRAMMER
OTHERWISE EXPIRE IN JULY AS YOU
HEARD FROM IS DEPUTY WHAT WAGE
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES
INCLUDE FUNDING FOR THE
EXPANSION OF SERVICES IN OUR
SERVICE POPULATION. BUT HAS NOT
PROPOSE CONTINUED FUNDING THE
TRAINING WHICH IS CRITICAL TO
CONTINUE GIVEN THE RECENT
EXPANSION AND GROWING SERVICE
DEMAND AND GENERAL ORDER ANY
ITEMS OF BACKUP PROVIDER
PROPOSAL WE'VE NOT SEEN THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT WE'RE
INTERESTED IN SEEING WHAT
CHANGES THEY THEN PROPOSED LAST
YEAR GIVEN THAT THE ISSUE DID
NOT MOVE FORWARD DUE TO
DIFFERENCES OF OPINION. AMONG
THE KEY STAKEHOLDERS WE ALSO
HAVE THE COUNTY BE PROVIDED WITH
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNDING FOR THE
NEW WORKLOADS THE- CERTAINLY
QUALITY A- AT THAT. AND FINALLY
WE THINK THAT AGING FROM WITH
WELCOME FOR SENDING OUT THE
GREAT FUNDING FOR TECHNOLOGY AND
BUILDING BY THE REFERENCE EARLY
IN THE- THANK YOU LOOKING YOU
CAN WORK WITH YOU ON THAT ARE.
AS WE MOVE FOR IN THE BUDGET THE
THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH COLOR
PLAY. NEXT WE'RE GOING NUMBER
THIRTY. PLANCHEREL NUMBER THAT
REALLY WHAT YOU NEEDLE THIRTY
NINE THIRTY THANK YOU FOR THE
HEARING TODAY WE APPRECIATE THAT
AND BUDGET THAT. IS THE
HIGHLIGHT UNITED HEAR IS
IMPORTANT DEVELOPMENT AN IDEA
DEPARTMENT BACK IN DECEMBER
FORWARD TO REVIEWING THE
UPCOMING TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
FOR EASY THE WE OUR WILL PRO THE
THING TAKING AND- PROVIDERS WILL
WILL NOT BE NICE AND- WE LOOK
FORWARD TO DISCUSSIONS ON ICE
CAREER PATH. JIM HERBERT
CREWMEMBER THE AND WORKING A LOT
TAKE A PARTNER LIMITS TO
INTENTIONAL I INVESTMENT OR
NATURAL PREPAREDNESS AND IS
REMINDED FOR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
COLOR PLEASE. WILL NOW GO TO
NUMBER FOUR. THANK YOU BUT I
THINK IF YOU KNOW TO KEEP
REPUBLICAN ON OF K. CASE STATE
BY BECAUSE HE OF PROGRAMS OF ALL
INCLUSIVE FOR THE- TODAY BECAUSE
ON THE PORT OF THE PART OF AGING
PROPOSED TO CONTINUE THE- OF THE
NOT PLAN AGING. ON THE- HEALTH
SURE SURE THAT LONGER FOR ME
NUMBER. CONNECTION TO. THE
SERVER FOR ALL OF. INCLUDING
CASE PRO THAT HE ELDERLY FRAIL
AND- NOW. HOME ADDITIONALLY ARE
PEACE OF THE THREE THOUSAND OF
THE DAY GOVERNMENT PAYMENT
REPORT. TO START THAT AGAIN ONE
TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE. THANKS TO
FOUR THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND DR PAN AM CHAMPION
LEAST PRASAD WITH CALIFORNIA'S
DECISION AT THE BANK THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
TODAY CAP'S VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THE PARTIAL REVERSAL OF GREAT
RECESSION ERICA STATUS DE IN THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET
HOWEVER AT THE L. A. AS PRIMARY
SECOND REPORT STATE THESE
INVESTMENTS PAIRED WITH FEDERAL
COLLEGE WILL STILL NOT BRING AT
THE TIME RECIPIENTS. OF FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL WHICH THEY WERE
PRIOR TO THE GREAT RECESSION
CUTS IN TWO THOUSAND NINE AND
WITHOUT AN INCREASE AT THE KEY
IN THE UPCOMING BUDGET YEAR I
THANK GRANT WILL DROP FROM 92%
OF THE L. 89% OF THAT YEAH AND
THEN BACK ONLY 92% OF FPL IN
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR WITH THE
REMAINDER OF THE CUTS. THAT THE
REVERSE. OF THE CAT. WE SHOULD
NOT. DYING BACK AND FORTH AND
BRING. POWER HERE'S PEOPLE
WITHIN THE HAVE AN EXTRA. TO
TIME MANAGING. NEEDS AND COUNT
EVERY PENNY. THIS MEANS AND WHAT
HE IS AS WELL. IT'S IS PEOPLE ON
A BY THE AND THEN PEOPLE OF
COLOR. TO DELIVER MY AND I.
THANK YOU VERY ASK YOU EXPELLER
. THE ANTENNA TO CREATE TO THE
BUDGET YEAR GO FOR A TO INCREASE
INTO THE GRANT TO FEDERAL POPPY
LEVEL THANK YOU VERY MUCH COLOR
. NOT OFF. THANKS FOR TO THE
FORTY EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON I
THINK IT ON OF JUSTICE THE
NATURE WE'D LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED
BUDGET FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING AND OF AGING
TO CREATE MORE PERMANENT. IN THE
IN OF THE MATH PLAN FOR AGING WE
ALSO LIKE TO OUR OUR SUPPORT FOR
THE INITIAL BUDGET MADE LAST
YEAR TO ADVANCE THE MASTER PLAN
FOR AGING. FINALLY WE ALSO LIKE
TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE
CONTINUED INVESTMENT IN
IMPROVEMENTS DIGEST THAT WOULD
HELP OLDER PEOPLE TO STAY IN
THEIR HOMES MY COLLEAGUE TRADE
BATTLE BE PROVIDING COMMENTS ON
ISSUE SIX RELATED BY S. AND P.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY. MUCH
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. NOW G TO
NUMBER. TWENTY EIGHT. CA.GOV
JUSTIN GARRETT CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES I KIND
OF HAVE BEEN ACTIVELY ENGAGED ON
IMPLEMENTATION A MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT THE
PROGRESS THAT STARTED PRECIADO
PROPOSED INVESTMENT IN THESE
EFFORTS ON IT SAYS WE LOOK
FORWARD TO ENGAGING FURTHER ON
THE BACK OF PROVIDED SYSTEM AND
SUPPORT PUBLIC ADMIN FUNDING FOR
COUNTY RECOMMENDATION OF THE
SYSTEM. AND FOR ATS WE
APPRECIATE THAT COMMITTEE
RECOGNIZING THAT YES TRAINING I
MEAN IS EXPIRING EITHER CONTINUE
TO BE A NEED FOR THIS FUNDING
AND THE FACTS OF COURSE THE
PROPOSAL. FOR A CONTINUATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALL PLEASE. THANKS TO
NUMBER FORTY SIX. ROBERT
COPELAND I BELONG TO THE SECOND
HOMES OR DELIVERY COMMITTEE I
THINK YOU SHOULD RAISE THE SFI
FLEX SS AMOUNT TO A FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL- THIS COMING. YEAR
IT. THE REASON ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE TO THEIR RIGHT NOW.
UNDER ARREST COULD BE AT HOME.
SO IF WE CAN PEOPLE IN THEIR
HOUSE. THIS MAY ACTUALLY OCCUR
SAVER. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR CALL NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT TO BE NUMBER FIFTY
TWO. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MIGHT CAROL WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW ALREADY I'M ALSO
CALLING ABOUT THE FINANCES- IN
ADDITION TO THE- BIG PREVIOUS
CALLERS TO EMERGE THAT THE-
INCREASE ON THE GRANT BE
ACCELERATED TO THE TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR BUT LEAVING THE
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE BUDGET
HERE SO THAT IT WOULD TAKE
EFFECT IN JANUARY WE'RE ALSO
LOOKING TO TRY TO GET AN
INCREASE. IN THE FUNDING AMOUNT
FOR THE F. AND B. THAT CAN BE
PROGRAMS THAT WERE PUT IN PLACE
WHEN WE ENDED THE BAR ON HOW
FRESH BENEFITS PRESS THE BY
RECIPIENT OF BOTH BRANCHES ARE
NOT CLOSER TO THE FEDERAL- SNAP
AMOUNTS WE COULD HAVE
INCREASINGLY GONE OUT AND
THEREFORE VOEPEL GOAL TO SORT OF
BEEN LEFT BEHIND. SO WE'RE
LOOKING TO GET THAT DONE IN
ADDITION TO CELEBRATING THE
GRANT INCREASE- FROM. FOUR TO
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TO TWENTY
TWENTY THREE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THANK. YOU VERY MUCH TAX
COURT PLEASE. NEXT BE NUMBER
FIFTY. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
REBECCA GONZALEZ OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKER
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE'RE ALSO
CALLING ABOUT THIS IS BY S. AND
P. PROGRAM WE APPRECIATE THAT
I'M INVESTMENTS MADE IN THE
BUDGET BUT AS YOU PROBABLY NOW
IN MANY COUNTIES THAT GRANT
WOULD NOT COVER THE COST OF THE
STUDIO APARTMENT AND RESPECT THE
AND ALSO NEED TO PAY FOR
UTILITIES. MATTAPAN TROLLEY
TRAIN CLOTHING AND OTHER
NECESSITIES AND LOW BRAND CAN
PUSH PEOPLE INTO HOMELESSNESS
AND HUNGER SO WE ALSO ASK
WHETHER WITH THE COLORATION OF
THE GRANT THE TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE FISCAL YEAR AND WE ASK
THAT THEY BE FULLY RESTORED BUT
THAT- THAT MEANS THAT I THINK
WHICH IS THAT WE NEED TO RESTORE
THE PURCHASING POWER INSTEAD OF
RESTORING THE JOB TO THE TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE LEVEL- I ALSO
WANT TO SUPPORT WHAT MY CHILD
SAID ABOUT THE G. THE F. AND B.
AND SHE CAN BE GRANT. AND LASTLY
I DO SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL
REFERENCE BY CWD A ON THE ATS
TRAINING PROGRAM FOR SOCIAL
WORKERS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WELL NOW GO TO NUMBER EIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON LIABILITY CHILD
LOS WE AGREE THE BECAUSE IN THAT
ADD MUCH THE DETAILS HE A WEEK
URGING QUESTION FUNDING TO
EXPAND THE WAIVER AND THE
VEHICLE COMMERCE THIRTY EIGHT AT
UNDER OUR CLASS- CDBG SACRAMENTO
CRASH MERRY AND DIDN'T GET PAID
. BASED ON I NEED RATHER THAN
ATTEND PASSED U. THIRTY THIS
YEAR EITHER HAVE TO THERE GINGER
CARE PROVIDER THEY OPEN AND
PARENTS CONDITIONS TO WORK FOR
THE FAMILIES THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS COLOR. THANK NUMBER FORTY FOUR.
AFTERNOON MARKET ON BEHALF OF
LEADING H. CALIFORNIA AND MY
THAT WERE ASKING FOR A ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR TWO PILOT PROGRAM
ADMINISTERED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF AGING DEFINES PROVIDE AND
BRING SOCIAL SERVICES AND
HEALTHCARE SERVICES AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SITES ENABLING OLDER
RESIDENTS REMAIN LIVING
INDEPENDENTLY AND AVOIDING
UNNECESSARY AND COSTLY
HEALTHCARE SERVICES SUCH AS
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT VISITS
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY FACE. THE COSBY
FIFTEEN MILLION FINDING THAT
HIGHLAND CALIFORNIA GREAT HELLO-
GRAHAM L. A. COUNTY ADAPTED FROM
VERMONT ALL OF THE COURTS AND
SERVICES THAT HELP FASHION MODEL
AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION FUNDING
FOR FIVE YOUR HEALTH YOUR HOMES
AGENT CRAIG HARRISON EIGHT
COUNTY ESCARPMENT AFTER PROGRAM
IN SACRAMENTO. YEAH ME AT ONE
POINT ONE MILLION AND MEDICAL
COSTS WE STRONGLY FEEL THAT THE
PROGRAM IN IMPORTANT BRIDGED
MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR CURRENT
ALL AND SO WE HAVE A STATEWIDE
COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAM IN PLACE.
YOU LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS WITH ME AND THE
APARTMENT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANKS NUMBER FORTY TWO. NAME-
CHAIR TOO MANY MY NAME IS JEREMY
RIPPLE BEHALF OF THE ALL
ASSOCIATION WE ARE OF NUMBER OF
PROPOSED IN THE- BY J. IS THE
REALLY TO THE DAY HEARING WORKS
I ABOUT BY THAT A GUY THE MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING IS KEEP. TO HELP
ALL HELP AND PROJECT THOSE WITH
IMPACT BY ALL AND- ADDITIONALLY
WORKING FOR A FUNDING STRENGTH
OF AGE OF PRO BROADLY THROUGH
THE CAREER LADDER AND BACK
APPROACH AS WELL IS THAT THE WE
WOULD HAVE BEEN REALLY TRAINING
. I WILL KNOW THAT ARE NATION
AND OFFERING AT THE SIXTY ONE
BANKS MONEY LIMON WHICH IS THAT
THE CARE NOW PROGRAM FOR HEALTH
WORK AND FROM AS FAR AS WITHIN
THE OF THE AND BUILD A THE
GOVERNOR BUDGET PROPOSAL. TO
HELP WORKERS SUPPORTING THOSE
LIVING WITH THE BILL LIKE THE A
BETTER OF THE COMMITTEE- WE
REVIEW THE FUTURE- A MUCH HOPING
- WILL BE SUPPORTED OF THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CALLING. FOR
NO WILL BE NUMBER. NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON SERICA
NOW MY NAME IS MY SONNTAG IN
CALL WITH THE SACKS OF MARIE
WILL BE. CALLING GARCIA S. I SS
GRANT COUNTY SHERIFF'S HOURS TO
WITH THAT NUMBERS WE DON'T FORTY
PRINTS ON AFTER HERE SIR. WE
KNOW MORE TO BE DONE ARE PEOPLE
LIKE TO CONTINUE TO ITS JOB THAT
YOU KNOW THIS PAYING BY MEDIC.
IN WORDS GOOGLE HOME ON.
ARMAGEDDON. MY HEALTH. WE'RE FOR
IT BECAUSE TO MAY NEVER START A
- I AM P. GRANTS BE BY YOUR
TOTAL TWENTY FOUR. BUT CAL HAS
MONEY TO GET IT DONE NOW YOU
TWENTY THREE. THOUSANDS ARE TO.
ON WHY WAY WE ARE HAVE THE MONEY
AND POWER TO MAKE. VALUE FOR
OVER TO YEARS AGO RIDE TODAY
ABOUT YOU. TO NINE DOLLAR TO
REFLECT NINETY DOLLARS THIS CUT
OFF BE A- WHERE WE'RE GONNA.
COLIN COULDN'T. PASSED THE
POVERTY THANK YOU. THANK VERY
MUCH THANKS CALL PLEASE. THANKS
WILL BE NUMBER FIFTY ONE. I
TRANSPONDERS JUSTICE ANYTHING
COMMENTING ON THIS OF BIASES THE
ITEM SPECIFICALLY THE DECLINE IN
THE MOMENT THE OF APPLYING FOR
DISABILITY BENEFITS YEAH AND
IT'S NOT GOTTEN ANY EASIER FOR
INDIVIDUALS. TO HOMELESSNESS
DON'T DISTINGUISH WELL OR HAVE A
COGNITIVE IMPAIRMENT YOU SEE AN
INDIVIDUAL SUCH STRUGGLE DURING
THE PANDEMIC. OFFICES BECAUSE-
BECAUSE THEY WERE LYING ON
IMPORTS AND HELP OTHER GOD. THIS
IS THE REASON WHY I. THE CRYING
DURING AND THEN I WOULD
OFFICIALLY REQUIRE BY OLDER
ADULTS AND WITH PRIMARY
LANGUAGES BY ENGLISH. IN ORDER
FOR THE EXERCISE BROWN TO WORK
FOLLOWING CAN HELP. FIRST WILL.
WHATEVER IS THEY CAN USE IMPROVE
WE EACH THE THIRD DON'T CASTLES
WHILE. CALIFORNIA THIS IS LISA
COLEMAN CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION. AND THE
CALIFORNIA ELDER JUSTICE
COALITION WE ARE STRONGLY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE NECESSARY
FUNDING FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE MASTER PLAN RAGING. THE
CIVICALLY WE LIKE TO CALL OUT-
THE FUNDING REQUEST FOR A BENCH
EASY WAY. THE CDA FOR THE
SEATTLE. OUR TO- PARTS OF ARE
CONTINUING SUPPORT FOR EIGHT.
BOB WE WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT
AT THE DATA FOR IN THE STAFF
ANALYSIS THE FUNDING FOR THE APS
TRAINING WILL EXPIRE AT THE END
OF THE FISCAL YEAR. AND IF THE
LEGISLATURE DOES CONSIDER
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL FUNDS TO
EXTEND THE TRAINING WE WOULD
REQUEST THAT LANGUAGE BE ADDED
TO INCLUDE IS THAT THE TRAINING
BE OPEN AND AVAILABLE TO THE
LOCAL LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
REPRESENTATIVES HAS APPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT COLOR PLEASE
. NEXT TO NUMBER FIFTY FIVE. THE
AFTERNOON EITHER FINANCIAL I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF ALAMEDA
COUNTY COMMUNITY FOOD BANK WE
ARE CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORTER
OF THE INVESTMENTS MADE TODAY I
HAVE TO KEEP PROGRAM IS NOT
RESTORING THE GRANT LET CUT
DURING THE GREAT RECESSION. WE
BELIEVE STRONGLY THAT THE TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE BUDGET BY
AND POVERTY FOR ONE POINT ONE
MILLION PEOPLE LIVING ON AFTER
HI WE QUITE OUT THAT DUE TO
GENDER AND RACIAL DISCRIMINATION
MOST AT THE END ARE WOMEN AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR. CODED NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAD EXACERBATE EXACTLY
AND JACK THIS IS AND SO WE MIGHT
EXHILARATED RESTORATION OF THE
GRANT WE ASKED THAT HE BE FULLY
RESTORED IN THE TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE QUESTIONS THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WELL NOW GO TO
NUMBER FORTY. THE NEW MEXICO
GOING TO DISABILITY RIGHTS- WE
APPRECIATE ALL THAT HE- ACCRUE
COMMITTEE AND THE FAMILY
COMMITTEE IT BELONG TO
COMPLETELY NEW- INCREASE THE
BUDGET BUT IT'S FOR SOME PEOPLE
WHO DID NOT GET THE GOLDEN STATE
GRANT THEY DID NOT- THEY DIDN'T
BENEFIT FROM THAT AND SO WE
WOULD LIKE TO- BECAUSE SHAKTI
INCREASE- FRANCIS I ASSIST YOU
RAISE THE TWENTY THREE TWENTY
GREAT GREAT ALLEN MAKE A LOT
MORE SENSE. AFTER COMMUNITY CARE
LICENSING WE BELIEVE THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE TO- BRING BACK A
QUALITY ASSURANCE SHE THAT WAS
THERE WHO ARE TO HELP INCREASE
INSPECTIONS FOR NURSING HOME
EITHER BRING IT AND RAISE IT IF
NECESSARY BECAUSE OUR CALL BUT
WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT'S
BEEN GOING ON IT FROM THE AREA.
AND SO ANYTHING THAT WOULD HELP
AND ACCESSIBILITY AND
IMPOSSIBILITY AND LIVABILITY
WE'RE ALL FOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIX
COLOR PLEASE. NEXT TO NUMBER
FIFTY. HI MY NAME IS DEBBIE
TELLS AND I'M CALLING FROM
CHOICE AND AIDING AND I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR- YOUR
PARTICIPATION AND LISTENING TO
ALL OF THE ADVOCATES I STRONGLY
IN SUPPORT OF THE NEW DIVISION
FOR THAT CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF EATING WHICH WILL BE CRITICAL
TO DEVELOPING THE EQUITY BUCKLEY
THREE THIRTEEN POLICY IN LINE
WITH THE GOALS OF THE MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING I WAS ONE OF THE
STAKEHOLDER ADVISORY COMMITTEE
MEMBER THAN ANYTHING THAT IS
FUNDING THE WORK THAT WE'VE DONE
I THINK IT'S- FANTASTIC I WANT
TO CALL YOUR ATTENTION TO THE
LACK OF PARITY. WHAT WE'RE
SPENDING ON OLDER ADULTS
COMPARED TO OTHER POPULATIONS
YET IT A LARGE AND GROWING
SEGMENT OF THE POPULATION I AM
SURE WE WILL BE COMING BACK WITH
BUDGET ACT INCLUDING THE- YEAH.
CENTERS ON AND THEY CAN. TO AND
THE PART OF THE- OF THE INCOMING
. BASED NETWORK OF SERVICES THE
NAME. THE INVESTMENT IN. OLDER
ADULTS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. MAX'S NUMBER SIXTY. BOB
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY YES HI
MY MOVES TO THE READING LINE AND
ALLOW NEITHER TWO THOUSAND AND
TWELVE ALMOST ALL WINTER SHOW
THEIR CHANGE VERY SOON- IN
OAKLAND ALSO A MEMBER OF THEIR
HOLDEN JUSTICE AND I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF THE COUNCIL OF
ELDERS I'M ALSO FINANCED ANTI
AND I'VE NOTICED EVERYTHING'S
BEEN GOING OUT HOUSING. CLOSE TO
AND MY ANSWER IS ACTUALLY STAYED
THE SAME WE WOULD REALLY BE
GREAT IF WE CAN CATCH UP TO
WHERE EVERYTHING ELSE IS GOING
AS FAR AS PRICE WISE. TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR SO WE CAN HAVE A GREATER
YOU KNOW RANDALL NORMAL
LIFESTYLE. I WOULD REALLY BE
GREAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT COLOR. AT THE SAME WE
HAVE NO OTHERS IN QUEUE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENTS. OKAY WELL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- YOU ARE PROMPTED
ONE MORE TIME. ASSEMBLY EARLY IN
GERMAN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENTS PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. WE DO HAVE ONE
ENTERING THE QUEUE TO BE JUST A
MOMENT. I WOULD HAVE ONE MORE
PERSON TO- WE'LL GO TO LINE
THIRTY THREE. THANK YOU MARTY
EMOTO FAMILY MEMBER CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY SENIOR COMMITTEE
ACTION NETWORK SO YOU CAN JUST
THANK THE MEMBER FOR THIS
HEARING AND ALSO INDICATE MY
SUPPORT FOR THE WESTERN CENTER
LAMPARD VISA DECISION ON IS THE
SITE IS THIS P. ALSO SHOUT OUT
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF BOTH THE
SERVICES. DEPARTMENT OF AGING-
YOU KNOW IF THEY'RE TREMENDOUS-
WORK. FOR ALL OF US THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CALL. AND NOW
IS IT MODERATOR N. AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO OTHERS IN Q. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR YOUR HELP AND EXPEDIENCY
TODAY. AND THAT THEN CONCLUDES
THIS- BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
HEARING A BUDGET SUB THREE. AND
WE WILL ADJOURN THIS MEETING.